[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
et dans son intégralité au sénat le
débat autour de l'application de ce
traçage stop qu'ovide plutôt en fin
d'après midi les députés ont approuvé la
mise en place de ce top qu'ovide 338
voix pour 215 voix contre et cela dans
un climat tendu
alors certes ce vote était consultatif
mais cédric au le secrétaire d'état au
numérique qui est également là ce soir a
annoncé qu'il ne déploieraient pas
l'application sans l'approbation du
parlement
ce vote a donc aussi son importance on
va voir la vie du sénat le sénat qui
commence on débat dans un quart d'heure
et je suis avec loïc hervé sénateur uc
de la haute savoie également membre de
la cnil
loïc hervé vous avez des réserves à
l'égard de cette application
après l'audition ce matin de cédric haut
et le débat à l'assemblée cet après midi
quel est votre avis alors j'ai plus que
des réserves puisque ce soir je voterai
contre comme un certain nombre de
membres de mon groupe
considérant que cette application sopko
vide est une mauvaise idée et et je
dirais que la réflexion qu'est la nôtre
elle se fonde sur l'efficience même du
dispositif et surtout l'atteinte aux
libertés publiques n'ont pas de cette
application
mais de toutes celles qui pourront
découler de l'invention de la
construction d'une architecture
numérique de traçage social car il ya
quand même eu des assurances sur cette
application effectivement la cnil dont
vous faites partie a pourtant validé
cette application elle considère qu'elle
est conforme aux rg le règlement
général sur la protection des données
rappelons bien à vos téléspectateurs
quel est le rôle de la cnil
la cnil qui d'une autorité
administrative indépendante qui existe
depuis 40 ans a pour rôle de vérifier
que les traitements de données sont
conformes à la loi de 78 et désormais
aux rg qu'est la loi européenne qui
permet de traiter sur le continent la
question des données personnelles
la question qu'on pose à l'acte il c'est
à dire est ce que cette application là
est conforme
effectivement au cadre législatif
national et européen dit
la réponse a été deux fois oui mais ces
deux avis de la cnil sont deux à vie
assortie de réserves de réserves
importantes et de contrôle qui seront
mises en oeuvre
moi ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui c'est
pas seulement la question propre du soft
coheed c'est les évolutions de notre
société vers ce qu'on appelle le
solutionner technologique qui fait qu'on
fait évoluer les consciences et qu'on va
progressivement d'une société de la
bienveillance vers le site et de la
surveillance vous craignez que
finalement cela soit utilisé à d'autres
sans à terme quelles fins donne un
exemple mais évidemment aujourd'hui nous
avons un gouvernement qui est
respectueux des valeurs de la république
et qui dit face à une pandémie on veut
mettre en place une application traçage
social très bien si demain contre le
terrorisme contre des mouvements sociaux
un gouvernant moins respectueux des
valeurs qui sont si chers à cette maison
arrivé au pouvoir il pourrait tout à
fait mettre en oeuvre ce type
d'application totalement construite et
construire une société de la
surveillance c'est bien ça qui est
inquiétant je mets ça vraiment dernier
par exemple ne vont pas être conservées
plus d'aimer bien sûr les garanties
seront apportés le ministre hall dira
elles seront l'application et de
téléchargement volontaire et puis on
supprimera les données au bout de 15
jours
et puis à la fin surprendra tout c'est
pas ça l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est un enjeu de
moyen long terme
progressivement on admet qu'une autorité
étatique prennent la main sur une telle
application et disent on va regarder
avec qui vous avez été en contact en
fait on renforce la sécurité alors que
dans mon esprit il faudrait renforcer la
responsabilité individuelle est donc
vraiment c'est une très mauvaise idée et
j'exprimerai ça tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle fermement vous avez commencé
à en parler tout acte tout à l'heure
vous pensez aussi que cela manquait
d'efficacité pour quelle raison ça
arrive un peu trop tard c'est vrai que
cette application l'attendait pour le
tout début du déconfinement c'était
d'ailleurs la maison en place au début
du confinement une application de ce
type là si on est dans l'esprit de la
mettre en oeuvre
esprit à la course difficile mais non
mais n'empêche que philosophiquement
encore et on la met en place au début du
continent c'est même une alternative au
confinement
on dit aux gens plus de liberté d'aller
et de venir plus liberté du commerce à
l'industrie on interrompt un processus
électoral au milieu entre les deux tours
et à ce moment là on pourrait c'est pas
mon avis mais on aurait pu justifier de
la mise en place d'une application de
traçage sociales y compris même
obligatoire en disant voilà ce qu'on met
en place parce que c'est important de
stopper l'épidémie
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui près
d'un mois après le déconfinement comment
se dire aux français si vous avez envie
vous pouvez librement télécharger cette
application avec toutes les questions
qu'on se pose autour de la technique de
la compatibilité de l'interopérabilité
on nous a même vendu un système européen
aujourd'hui on est les seuls à le mettre
en place dans ce monde n'est pas tirée
par aiguille d'autres pays d'europe
mettre en place un système apple google
à la fin on héritera d'un système
national centralisée français est
partout en europe d'un système porté par
les gaffes à qui sera décentralisée au
boucle au bout de l'opération va
s'arrêter ce système n'a pas du tout pas
du tout mais n'empêche que si on fait le
compte
au bout de l'opération on aura quand
même quelque chose qui sera extrêmement
grave et on aura franchi le dit de jeu
lui a dit vraiment ce soir dans
l'intervention que j'ai préparé on aura
franchi deux lignes rouges
une ligne nationale une ligne européenne
qui seront des lignes très grave
l'application apple google
elle sera installé par défaut sur les
téléphones et elle servira à d'autres
fins demain bon mais on voit que c'est
un vote énergiquement contre maire salue
mon cou loïc avant d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vais à présent accueil à
l'un des autres orateurs de cette soirée
le sénateur les indépendants de
maine-et-loire emmanuel capus bonsoir
bonsoir à vous allez intervenir tout à
l'heure pour votre groupe dans ce débat
sur l'application un stop qu'ovide est
ce que vous y êtes tout simplement
favorable à cette application est ce que
vous jugez que c'est une arme efficace
pour freiner les contaminations dans ce
moment du décompte final
je pense que c'est une arme efficace
dans les circonstances que vous avez
décrite parce que ma hantise la vraie
privation de liberté ça a été un
confinement yahia qui a bleus
il est assigné à résidence plusieurs
millions de français
on peut pas se permettre de reconnaître
de reconnaître un tel épisode de
confinement donc il faut qu'on utilise
tous les moyens à notre disposition dans
le respect des libertés individuelles et
je partage beaucoup de points de vue de
mes comptes de mes collègues sur le
respect des libertés individuelles
mais dans une proportionnalité dans une
respect d'une proportionnalité de cette
atteinte aux libertés individuelles
je pense que l'application stop qu'ovide
ne porte pas trop atteinte et peut être
utilisé et peut permettre d'éviter une
atteinte encore plus grande à nos
libertés c'est à dire leur confinement
vous craignez leur compte d'alleurs loïc
hervé à l'instant contraire jugent et
bien que ça trop tard qu'il aurait fallu
avoir cette application dès le début du
confinement écrin à la fois et bien le
manque d'efficacité et puis les attentes
aux libertés publiques et surtout les
risques potentiels pour la suite c'est
pas la panacée
on aurait pu effectivement mettre en
place l'application plus tôt mais le
gouvernement a eu le souci et je partage
ce souci de faire une application
française pas dans les mains des gars
femmes pas dans les mains des deux pays
étrangers on reste on respecte notre
souveraineté numérique et c'est
peut-être un premier pas vers la
souveraineté numérique de la france donc
c'est plus lent mais au moins c'est plus
sécurisant fait que les données sont
aussi centralisé là où elles ne sont pas
avec l'autre les autres applications de
moi je préfère qu'elles soient
centralisées j'ai plus confiance dans le
gouvernement démocratique français que
dans des sociétés privées qui peuvent
revendre les données mais effectivement
c'est il faudra être extrêmement
vigilant je pense que l'application qui
nous est proposée par est respecté cet
équilibre notamment avec la possibilité
de contrôler le mécanisme d'ouverture
des codes sources qui permet justement
le contrôle de la maîtrise de ses
données
je dis pas encore une fois je dis pas
que c'est la panacée je vous dis juste
que je voterai pour est-ce que quinze
jours après le déconfinement alors que
certains adding habitudes sont déjà
prises vous ne pensez pas que les gens
ne vont pas forcément la télécharger je
pense que c'est mieux que rien quoi
qu'il arrive quand même à taux de
couverture de la population qui est trop
faible pour que cela soit finalement
efficace
on peut pas dire comme moi qu'il faut
respecter la liberté de choix des
individus respecter la responsabilité
individuelle et l'imposer et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des ehdaa beaucoup moins
démocratique que nous qui impose de la
géolocalisation qui impose le contrôle
des données
ça n'est pas le choix de la france ça
n'est pas la tradition française
donc effectivement en efficacité ça sera
sans doute moins efficace mais ça
respecte aussi l'idée que nous avons de
la démocratie et du respect des libertés
je pense quand même que ça va être
efficace dans le sens où les personnes
que nous croisons dans le métro que nous
croisons dans le bus que nous croisons
dans les zones urbaines
nous ne connaissons pas leur nom nous ne
savons pas qui sec donc nous ne pouvons
pas indiqué qu' elles sont pour les
enquêteurs sanitaire qui ne pourront pas
les appeler en cas de contact avec un
malade
un mot enfin sur la tenue de ce débat le
secrétaire d'état au numérique nous a
dit ce matin qu il bien une déploierait
l'application que s'il y avait un vote
positif du parlement il y en a eu 1
positif à l'assemblée mais dans un
climat d'extrême tension s'était quand
même extrêmement divisée je comprends
très bien la division parce que nous
avons tous le même objectif c'est le
respect des libertés individuelles et
c'est un livre encore une fois je lis ça
n'est pas la panacée
personnellement je pense que l'
équilibre basse penche du côté de la
mise en place de cette application
parce que ma crainte c'est de
reconnaître un épisode de privation de
liberté telle qu'on l'a connue qu'on
n'avait pas connu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale une dernière question
est ce que votre avis représente celui
de votre groupe lui la limité du groupe
votera pour
enfin nous voterons tous pour cette
application eh bien merci beaucoup
emmanuel capus d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et enfin je vais accueillir le
sénateur pierre laurent sénateur
communiste de paris à bonsoir pierre
laurent votre groupe est plutôt opposés
à l'appli est up coville pour quelles
raisons d'abord les conditions
de préparation ce débat n'ont pas été
celles qu'on attendait le premier
ministre avait dit on passera par un
débat par le parlement mais on passe le
débat oui mais dans des conditions qui
sont pas celles où on présente un texte
qu'on peut discuter amender etc
on va avoir un débat général et on vote
à la sortie donc on donne en quelque
sorte quitus au gouvernement pour une
application sur laquelle nous n'obtenons
pas malgré nous demande mais les
demandes de deux parlent de
parlementaires d'autres sensibilités que
la note des garanties de sécurité et de
protection des libertés que nous
n'obtenons toujours pas avec clarté et
comme l'enjeu est extrêmement important
notamment du point de vue de la
protection des données personnelles
nous ne pouvons pas en l'état donné
notre accord à l'appli à la mise en
oeuvre de cette application stop-gain
les deux avis de la cnil ne vous
suffisent pas notamment celui d'hier qui
approuve cette appli stop covin dans
l'état où elle lui a été présentée pas
en l'état justement qu'il approuve en
demandant en demandant des modifications
et des précisions dont nous n'avons pas
pour le moment le résultat donc en fait
ce qu'on nous demande ce soir c'est de
donner je le répète quitus au
gouvernement pour mettre en oeuvre
mais comme depuis le début de cette
affaire nous demandons justement qui est
un débat beaucoup plus transparent et un
contrôle beaucoup plus transparente
cette application dont il semble quand
même et beaucoup d'experts nous le
disent qu'elles risquent de ne pas être
totalement sécurisé totalement au point
et on ne peut pas se permettre une
expérimentation en marche au elle se
fera en tout cas sur la base du vol
est-ce que la situation actuelle
exceptionnelle d'un point de vue
sanitaire ne justifie pas d'avoir
recours à tous les moyens possibles
surtout si on est sur la base du
volontariat
il ya beaucoup de moyens exceptionnels
qui ont été mis en oeuvre et beaucoup
d'autres qui doivent continuer à être
mis en oeuvre parce qu'effectivement il
n'y a pas de débat sur le fait qu'on
doit déployer le maximum de moyens
sanitaires mais ce qui est quand même
assez curieux c'est qu'on nous demande
d'aller très vite sur cette application
alors que par exemple sur beaucoup
d'autres questions ou posons par exemple
amis
on conformité sanitaire de tous les
plans de reprise d'emploi d'activité
pour les salariés
là on est beaucoup plus on est beaucoup
plus lâches sur le contrôle donc oui
bien sûr que nous nous sommes favorables
à ce que tous les moyens soient mises en
oeuvre mais qu'ils soient mises en
oeuvre dans de bonnes conditions et on
sait depuis le départ que cette
application
je le répète pose des problèmes de
protection des données personnelles
toute particulière et nous considérons à
ce stade de ce qui est en notre
connaissance que les garanties ne nous
sont pas suffisamment donné sur ce
projet alors le gouvernement a répété
que sa part le mois il n'y aurait pas de
déploiement de l'application
il n'y a pas eu tellement de suspens
avec le vote de l'assemblée nationale
est ce qui a encore un enjeu
avec ce vote du sénat pour vous bah on
nous donc de voter donc heureusement
qu'on va le faire et on va le faire ont
conscience donc nous nous n'approuverons
pas la mise en application en l'état de
deux stops qu'ovide d'autres le diront
mais ce qui est dommage c'est que le
gouvernement dit il nous faudrait
l'approbation du parlement mais sur un
sujet pareil parce que tu es est un
sujet qui touche aux libertés
fondamentales
on aurait dû créer les conditions d'un
consensus est d'ailleurs le premier
ministre avait dit on passera par un
débat parlement pour obtenir le
consensus
là manifestement il n'y aura pas de
consensus c'est donc pas une bonne
nouvelle de mettre en oeuvre cette
application d'ailleurs le gouvernement a
annoncé en fait la mise en oeuvre de
l'application avant même que le débat se
tienne tout en disant que mon kayak
halte à dire qu'on dit parlant elle
était déjà réellement les égards parc on
a l'impression que le vote qu'on nous
demande ce soir c'est un peu de la
parade mais en vérité tout est déjà
décidé dans l'esprit du web plutôt d'une
validation car allant vous quoi qu'il
arrive une validation sans possibilité
d'agir sur les garanties que nous de
nous est-ce que vous jugez que et bien
dans le contexte actuel est bien le
parlement et la place qu'il méritait
tout au long de cette époque du
confinement du déconfinement aujourd'hui
on le voit il ya quand même encore une
fois se débarrasse d'un nombre de textes
qui sont passés non nous ne le pensons
pas
bon le parlement a essayé de jouer son
rôle de contrôle bien sûr on a
auditionné beaucoup de ministres mais
pendant toute cette période il ya
énormément de décisions qui ont été
prises par décret par ordonnance on a
donné beaucoup de marge au gouvernement
sans avoir réellement les moyens de
contrôler dans de bonnes conditions
d'ailleurs nous on avait alerté sur sade
est le premier état d'urgence
on la refait au second et ça se vérifie
eh bien merci beaucoup cas laurent
d'avoir répondu à mes questions va
rejoindre tout de suite et bien à
l'hémicycle du sénat où va se dérouler
et bien ce débat pendant un petit peu
plus de deux heures vous le voyez un
jean marc gabouty va présider la séance
quelques mots il va y avoir et bien les
interventions de trois ministres la
garde des sceaux nicole belloubet la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la santé christelle du boss et enfin
cédric ruault
le secrétaire d'état au numérique qui
est d'ailleurs à la manoeuvre dans ce
dossier puis 8
orateur du sénat un parent groupes
s'exprimeront pendant 45 minutes avant
un débat interactif cette fois ci avec
onze questions réponses et enfin le vote
qui devrait intervenir à un petit peu
avant minuit tout de suite donc on prend
la direction de l'observation du
gouvernement la parole sera donnée un
orateur de chaque groupe
puis après l'éventuelle réponse du
gouvernement nous procéderons à une
séquence de 11 questions réponses
enfin nous procéderons au vote par
scrutin public en application l'article
39 de notre règlement sur cette
déclaration
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la ministre je remercie monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la crise sanitaire que nous vivons et
qui frappe le monde entier a une
dimension inédite cette situation qui
est exceptionnel par sa gravité par les
deuils et les sacrifices qu'elle a
imposés à beaucoup de nos concitoyens
cette situation nous oblige à apporter
des réponses adaptées
nous avons le devoir d' envisager toutes
les solutions possibles et de mobiliser
toutes les ressources pour mettre un
terme à cette situation la volonté et
l'obligation du gouvernement
et que son action s'inscrive dans ce
domaine sans exception possible dans le
cadre des valeurs de notre démocratie
c'est à dire le respect de l'état de
droit et des libertés individuelles
c'est en nous conformant à cette
exigence que nous pourrons conserver la
confiance de nos concitoyens les
services numériques offrent évidemment
d'immenses opportunités vous le savez
durant la crise ils ont démontré leur
intérêt et leur potentiel dans le
domaine des consultations en
télémédecine qu'il s'agisse également du
télétravail ou bien de l'école à 10 ans
encore faut-il que ces outils numériques
soit utilisé dans un cadre protecteur et
respectueux des droits de chacun cet
encadrement a été bâtie adapté
perfectionner progressivement afin de
garantir à chaque personne
la protection de ses droits fondamentaux
du respect de sa vie privée et de ses
données à caractère personnel la france
et vous le savez puisque vous en avez
été acteur a toujours été à
l'avant-garde de la protection des
données et de la garantie des libertés
individuelles dans ce domaine la loi
informatique et libertés du 6 janvier
1978 nous a permis d'être le premier
pays en europe à se doter d'un texte
général fondateur protégeant les données
à caractère personnel et c'est cette loi
qui a créé la commission nationale
informatique et libertés dont nous
savons aujourd'hui encore combien elle
est indispensable
l'union européenne pour sa part a
élaboré d'ailleurs sous l'impulsion de
la france entre autres à élaborer un
cadre juridique harmoniser et protecteur
pour les citoyens européens pour
l'utilisation de leurs données à
caractère personnel
ainsi la directive deee prize si vie
privée et télécommunications
électroniques du 12 juillet 2002 permet
de garantir la protection de la vie
privée lorsque des correspondances
empreintes des moyens de communications
électroniques
l'adoption du règlement général sur la
protection des données de 2016 qui est
plus connu sous son acronyme hergé
cette protection a fait l'objet de
débats nourris dans votre assemblée même
en 2018 et 7
ce texte
or mais une porte est tout à fait
considérable ces textes donc nationaux
européens n'interdisent d'aucune manière
l'utilisation des données personnelles
dans le cadre d'une stratégie sanitaire
mais ces textes ont posé deux grands
principes auxquels doit se conformer
tout traitement de données à caractère
personnel
ces grands principes constituent des
garanties pour le respect de notre vie
privée et de nos libertés individuelles
trois de ces principes qui sont définies
à l'article 5 du rgp des constitue une
base un socle essentiel qui doit être
ici mentionné le premier principe c'est
celui dit de la limitation des finalités
principe cardinal de la protection des
données à caractère personnel
il établit que ces données ne doivent
être utilisés que pour un objectif
précis et déterminé à l'avancé selon les
termes mêmes du rgp des le traitement
doit répondre à une finalité déterminé
explicite et légitime déterminé parce
qu'il n'est pas possible de collecter
des données sans but ou à des fins
préventives explicite parce que les
personnes concernées doivent savoir
pourquoi et comment leurs données sont
traitées est légitime parce que le
traitement doit être en rapport avec
l'activité du responsable du traitement
principe de limitation des finalités
mais aussi principe de licéité c'est le
deuxième principe un traitement doit en
effet se fonder sur l'une des bases
juridiques limitativement énumérées par
le rg bd que cela soit le consentement
des personnes
l'exécution d'un contrat ou l'exécution
d'une mission d'intérêt public et ce
sera le cas ici enfin troisième principe
le principe dit de minimisation des
données ou principe de proportionnalité
cela pardonnez moi signifie que l'on ne
peut traiter que les données pertinentes
est strictement nécessaire au regard de
la finalité poursuivie par le traitement
ces principes ont été respectées pour
chacun des outils numériques mises en
place par le gouvernement pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de l'aco vite
9 qu'il s'agisse de contacts qu vide ou
du sein du système d'information
national de dépistage appelé cidep de
traitement autorisé par le décret du 12
mai dernier
ils permettent d'identifier les
personnes infectées les personnes
qu'elles sont susceptibles d'avoir
contaminé et les chaînes de
contamination ce traitement vise
également à assurer la prise en charge
sanitaire et l'accompagnement des
personnes atteintes du virus ou
susceptibles de l'être ainsi que la
surveillance épidémiologique du virus
l'appellation stop qu'ovide à respecter
les mêmes principes posés par le rg bdl
complète
elle complète les outils développés dans
le cadre de la stratégie de
déconfinement progressif que le
gouvernement souhaitait mettre en place
ces trois dispositifs utiles qui utilise
des données à caractère personnel et qui
s'inscrivent donc dans une politique
sanitaire globale ont été soumis à
l'avis de la cnil qui a donné un avis
favorable
cette application a d'ailleurs fait
l'objet de deux avis de la cnil
l'un du 24 avril et l'autre du 25 mai
clay cnil qui s'est félicité dans son
dernier avis celui du 25 mai que ses
premières recommandations et était suivi
par le gouvernement elle a donc donné un
avis favorable
cela a aussi était le cas cela à otsi
était le cas pour l'avis rendu par le
conseil national du numérique
stop que vides répondent aux exigences
posées par notre droit est me
semble-t-il apporte les garanties
nécessaires au respect de la vie privée
et des libertés individuelles
cela résulte à la fois de ce qu'est
l'application stop vide et de ce qu'elle
n'est pas peut-être ce qu'elle n'est pas
tout d'abord le ministre de la santé ma
collègue christelle du boss et le
secrétaire d'état au numérique que je
salue et qui sont ici à mes côtés
exposeront précisément ces questions
mais il me paraît d'emblée primordial de
préciser qu'il ne s'agit en aucun cas de
procéder à la géolocalisation des
personnes ou à 1
suivi intrusif de leurs déplacements
l'utilisation de la technologie
bluetooth solution recommandée par la
commission européenne dans sa
communication du 16 avril permet à la
fois plus de précision ce que la
géolocalisation
tout en étant moins intrusive en ce
qu'elle ne permet pas le pistage des
personnes nul ne sait où la personne est
allé ni où elle a rencontré d'autres
personnes susceptibles d'avoir été
infectés
on sait seulement que des personnes ont
croisé l'utilisateur de l'application
stop que vide n'a d'ailleurs pas non
plus vocation à permettre un quelconque
fichage des français ou à contrôler leur
respect des mesures sanitaires
le décret créant cette application sera
d'ailleurs très clair en précisant
expressément ce à quoi elle peut servir
j'ai dit ce que n'était pas stable que
vide quelques mots maintenant sur ce
qu'est cette application il apparaît
nécessaire dans le cadre de la stratégie
globale de déconfinement du gouvernement
non seulement d'être capable
d'identifier ce que l'on appelle les cas
contacts et qui sont les proches des
personnes infectées connu de ces
dernières mais aussi d'être en mesure
d'alerter tous les autres ces inconnus
croisés dans les transports ou dans les
magasins et qu'ils ont pu être
contaminées sans le savoir
il s'agit ainsi de juguler aussi
rapidement que possible et aussi
efficacement que possible les chaînes de
contamination c'est là l'objectif de
cette application
et c'est donc bien sur le fondement de
l'exécution d'une mission d'intérêt
public d'une mission d'intérêt public
que ce traitement sera mise en oeuvre
sous la responsabilité du ministère de
la santé
de nombreuses autres garanties entoure
ce traitement conformément aux
préconisations de la cnil
j'en citerai 4 l'utilisation volontaire
de cette application
à chaque étape le consentement des
personnes est requis et leur choix est
garanti
le téléchargement de l'application
résulte d'une démarche volontaire de
l'utilisateur son installation est libre
et gratuite
les fonctionnalités ne pourront être
activés que si l'utilisateur le souhaite
et la désinstallation sera possible à
tout moment si un test naso pharyngé
permettent à lui à l'utilisateur de
savoir qui n'est potentiellement
contaminants il ne le notifiera dans
l'application que s'ils le souhaitent
recourir ou non à l'application est donc
un choix que chacun d'entre nous pourra
faire notre liberté est ainsi préservé
et garanti précision capital pour que
cette liberté soit garantie aucune
conséquence négative n'est attachée au
choix de ne pas recourir à cette
application
l'accès aux tests et aux soins la
liberté d'aller et de venir
l'accès aux transports en commun ne sont
pas conditionnées à l'installation et à
l'utilisation de l'application il ne
saurait non plus y avoir de conséquences
sur la vie professionnelle
de même ni son installation ni son
utilisation ne donne droit à aucun droit
ou avantages spécifiques le consentement
est donc libre conformément à notre
droit national et à la réglementation
européenne que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
c'est donc le premier la première des
garanties la deuxième garantie c'est la
pseudonyme isation l'installation de
l'application ne reculera pas la
fourniture de données directement
identifiantes comme le nom ou l'adresse
seuls des pseudonymes éphémères seront
utilisés ni l'état ni personne d'autre
n'aura accès à une liste de personnes
diagnostiquées positive ou à une liste
des interactions sociales entre les
utilisateurs
la 3e 3e garantit la conservation des
données pour une durée extrêmement
limité les données ne pourront être
conservées que pendant la durée de
fonctionnement de l'application le
caractère temporaire de l'application
j'insiste sur cet aspect temporaire le
dont le terme est la mise en oeuvre dont
le terme pardon de la mise en oeuvre est
fixé à 6 mois à une durée qui correspond
à celle prévue pour les traitements
contacts que vides et cidep
l'application n'ayant en réalité
d'utilité qu'en lien avec le cadre plus
général de conduite d état sanitaire
plus encore les historiques de proximité
ne pourront être conservées que quinze
jours durée strictement nécessaire au
regard de la durée d'incubation du virus
plus important encore l'utilisateur
pourra à tout moment demander la
suppression de ces données tant de son
ordi fun que du serveur central
enfin dernière garantit la transparence
l'application stop qu'ovide s'inscrit
dans une démarche de transparence
les utilisateurs seront informés des
principales caractéristiques du
traitement et de leurs droits au moment
de l'installation de l'application stop
qu'ovide respecte donc strictement la
législation applicable en matière de
protection des données à caractère
personnel et les préconisations de la
commission européenne du comité européen
de protection des données et de la cnil
que neil avec laquelle d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a travaillé à plusieurs
reprises en étroite collaboration stop
que vide et donc si je devais me résumer
stop que vides et volontaire temporaires
non et non identifiantes et
transparentes
toutes les garanties me semble-t-il sont
donc prises pour que la vie privée des
français soit respectée
cette application et ce seront mes mots
de conclusion cette application n'a pas
vocation à devenir l'élément central de
la lutte contre la copie 19
elle ne constitue pas plus un moyen
déguisé
pour ériger un état policier contrôlant
les faits et gestes de nos concitoyens à
juste titre la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme a
souligné et je la cite qu'il s'agit de
sujets de préoccupation majeur dans une
société démocratique
nécessitant une transparence accrue et
des garanties suffisantes pour pallier
les risques d'atteinte transversale aux
droits et libertés fondamentaux cette
vigilance me semble-t-il est ici pris en
compte par l'ensemble des garanties que
j'ai évoquées par notre vigilance
collective par le débat démocratique qui
se déroule notamment avec vous mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et
dessinatrice et cela permet d'envisager
cette application comme un outil
précieux au service des citoyens au
service de leur santé sans nier leur
liberté je vous remercie
merci à la ministre un la parole et même
en mal à me christelle du boss
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la dangerosité
du virus n'est plus à prouver
la france comme tous les pays du monde
et encore lourdement le prix de cette
crise nous avons entamé le 11 mai une
nouvelle phase celle du déconfinement le
combat n'est tout pas n'est toutefois
pas terminée et nous devons étudier tous
les outils qui nous permettront de
vaincre le virus le sujet du débat qui
nous réunit ce soir est celui de la
pertinence et de la juste mesure
la première question est la suivante
l'application stop coded est elle
efficace
de nombreuses études épidémiologiques
montrent l'intérêt pour les autorités
sanitaires de pouvoir disposer
d'applications de suivi de contact en
appui aussi vu au suivi manuel de
propagation des chaînes de transmission
en effet l'utilisation de telles
applications permet d'alerter les
contacts anonyme par exemple dans les
transports ou dans les commerces
ce qui constitue un gain de temps et de
ressources
beaucoup d'experts soutiennent utilité
de cette application dans le cadre de la
stratégie de contact racing le contact
racing est désormais au centre de la
stratégie de déconfinement puisque c'est
le seul instrument permettant de rompre
les chaînes de transmission ainsi que
vous l'avez voté il ya quelques semaines
le suivi des contacts et réal et est
réalisée manuellement au moyen d'une
enquête auprès de la personne malade qui
transmet la liste des personnes avec qui
elle aurait été en contact ainsi que les
lieux publics visités durant sa période
de contagiosité
cette action de tracking n'est pas
nouvelle cette méthodologie est
largement utilisé en veille sanitaire
pour bon nombre de pathologies
infectieuses à transmission interhumaine
le contact racing repose sur les
professionnels de santé les médecins de
ville et les biologistes pour la
réalisation des tests et les infirmiers
pour les prélèvements avec le soutien
appuyé des agents de l'assurance maladie
ces équipes d'anges gardiens sont
indispensables pour intervenir
rapidement et casser les chaînes de
contamination les dernières données
montrent que près de 45% des
transmission du virus se font à partir
de personnes asymptomatiques
l'enjeu est ainsi de repérer très
précocement les cas contacts c'est l'une
des possibilités que nous offre les
solutions numériques qui ont été très
travaillé elles ne viennent pas en
substitution du contact racing mise en
place par l'assurance maladie
elles viennent en appui l'application
stop qu'ovide permet ainsi de repérer
plus précocément de potentiel qu'à
contacter qui auront alors avec 24 ou 48
heures d' avance les bons réflexes de
s'isoler de consulter un médecin et de
se faire tester
est ce que nous arrivons trop tard je ne
le pense pas car notre stratégie de
contact racing ne repose pas uniquement
sur les outils numériques comme c'est le
cas par exemple de certains pays
asiatiques
l'académie de médecine a émis un avis
favorable à l'utilisation d'une
application du type stop qu'ovide dans
le cadre du déconfinement afin de
permettre une participation active de la
population dans la lutte contre la
pandémie tout en respectant l'anonymat
et la réglementation européenne et
nationale du rgp des dames et messieurs
les sénateurs
j'en viens maintenant à la question
éthique puisque un moyen efficace n'est
pas nécessairement un moyen légitime au
gouvernement comme sur ces bancs nous
partageons tous le même objectif
protéger les français et je rejoins
plusieurs d'entre vous qui estime que
nous ne produisons pas bien les français
si par ailleurs nous portons atteinte
aux libertés qui protègent leur vie
privée
dès lors comment concilier ces deux
protections en assumant la transparence
vous le savez ce top cow vide a été
développé sous la supervision du
ministère des solidarités de la santé et
du secrétariat d'état chargé du
numérique dans son avis rendu au mois
d'avril le conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins a précisé ses
recommandations en matière d'utilisation
du numérique dans la période d'épidémie
ces recommandations ont été suivies
l'institut national de recherche en
sciences et technologies du numérique a
été chargé de développer un prototype
d'application et d'instruire les
différentes questions techniques
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information a également été
sollicité pour garantir la résilience et
la sécurité des solutions étudiées
enfin la cnil a été étroitement associés
dans le respect de son indépendance afin
d'apporter toutes les garanties
nécessaires de la protection de la vie
privée comme vient de le rappeler madame
la garde des sceaux
le projet a dès sa phase de construction
impliquées d équipe d'épidémiologistes
de santé publique france et de la
direction générale de la santé pour
l'inscrire dans la stratégie sanitaire
de déconfinement du gouvernement la
transparence est une clé essentielle de
ce top cow vide la protection de la vie
privée est un principe avec le cas
ne transigerons pas l'application stop
qu'ovide ne doit pas passer pour autre
chose que ce qu'elle est
fondamentalement elle était un simple
outil de lutte contre une épidémie
redoutable un outil efficace et je le
crois profondément
un outil légitime mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs en conclusion j'aimerais
dire quelques mots sur la place
qu'occupe le numérique depuis le début
de la crise le ministère des solidarités
et de la santé a mis en place un service
service officiel de prévention et de
conseils personnalisés
c'est le site mes conseils qu'ovide
point fr qui permet à chacun de nos
concitoyens de bénéficier d'informations
utiles pour se protéger et pour protéger
les autres c'est un outil qui intervient
en amont de l'entrée dans le parcours de
soins et conseils sont personnalisées en
fonction de la situation médicale
familiale professionnelle et
géographique de l'utilisateur sans qu'il
n'y ait de stockage de données sur un
serveur central dans la période de
déconfinement je le redis la stratégie
est de tester tester tester
nous avons ainsi mis en ligne sur le
site sante.fr une carte géolocaliser de
tous les lieux de prélèvement des tests
virologiques pour le dépistage du coc
vide
les informations sont renseignés
directement par les laboratoires de
biologie médicale et je les remercie de
la réactivité dans ce projet mené avec
l'adresse depuis le lancement du service
il ya quelques jours la carte a été
consulté plus de 400 mille fois
permettant de trouver les quelques 3000
100 sites de prélèvement enfin c'est
toute la société française qui s'est
mobilisée et son lot de start up et
d'éditeurs de la e-santé qui ont
rivalisé et d'innovation pour lutter
contre la copie de 19
afin de soutenir ce formidable élan et
accompagner les citoyens les
professionnels les établissements de
santé dans leur choix d'outils
numériques
le gouvernement a lancé une plate-forme
de référencement un véritable guichet de
l'innovation numérique qu'ovide à ce
jour ce sont plus de 200 services
qui sont déjà référencés sur la
plateforme plusieurs outils de
téléconsultation et des dalles
orientations pour les citoyens sont par
exemple liste et mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la période que nous
traversons et de laquelle j'espère ne
sortiront progressivement est l'occasion
de montrer que notre pays est capable
d'utiliser toute son ingéniosité tout
son inventivité toute sa créativité pour
lutter contre les effets de cette
pandémie mondiale
mais ceci tout en conservant bien ancrer
ses principes fondateurs
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant à monsieur cédric au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie des finances et du ministre
d'action et des comptes publics chargée
du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices ces messieurs les sénateurs
il s'agit je crois de la première fois
où un logiciel informatique mobilise
ainsi à lui seul le parlement pour un
débat et pour un vote à cette assemblée
bien sûr nous nous sommes déjà
rencontrés a déjà eu l'occasion de
débattre de l'utilisation des outils
numériques de leurs impacts et des
limites qu'il convient de leur poser
mais jamais le gouvernement et le
parlement ne se sont ainsi retrouvés
autour d'un sujet qui est à la fois
aussi restreint mais qui porte en lui
des questions bien plus profonde s'il
s'agit donc d'une première il ne s'agit
probablement pas d'une dernière ce que
nous savions mais que le confinement a
révélé de manière paroxystique
c'est à quel point le numérique est
devenue la colonne vertébrale de notre
société de notre économie et même de nos
institutions
cette dorsale elle a ses propres
déterminant et ses propres règles que le
champ législatif et l'action politique
mais connaissent trop souvent les
langages du droit et de la loi montagne
sont à nos yeux une noblesse que le code
informatique n'a pas encore même si le
temps pourtant souvent allait supplanter
se sont l'intelligence artificielle et
les algorithmes qui décide qui décident
pardon de plus en plus à notre place et
pourrait reproduire ou amplifier les
inégalités du monde réel si nous n'y
prenons garde
par exemple les inégalités de genre
ce sont les réseaux sociaux qui ancre
malheureusement notre quotidien dans la
culture et le droit anglo saxon ce sont
les moteurs de recherche qui archivent
notre accès à l'information et formate
nos débattent notre débat démocratique
se soit enfin mille autres exemples qui
témoignent de l'urgence d'inscrire le
numérique au coeur du travail de nos
institutions non pas comme une matière
en soi mais comme une grammaire qui
détermine toutes les autres bien sûr
l'application stop qu'ovide à l'aune de
ces débats anthologique
on est en soi que peu de choses la
polémique qui l'a accompagné en dit du
reste probablement un peu plus de nous
que de l'application elle-même
j'y reviendrai il convient donc avant
toute chose de préciser ce qu'est stop
qu'ovide le principe de l'application
mult de présenter à de multiples
reprises et simple dès lors que vous
aurez choisi volontairement bien sûr de
l'installer l'application historise
rassure téléphone portable la liste des
personnes possédant évidemment elle
aussi d'applications croisés pendant
plus de 15 minutes à moins d'un mètre
sans que vous connaissiez ne connaissiez
jamais leur identité dès lors que vous
seriez testé positif stop peut vite vous
donnera la possibilité de notifier
volontairement et instantanément ces
mêmes personnes qu'elles ont été en
contact avec une personne contaminée au
co vide afin qu'elles puissent isoler
rentrer en contact avec un médecin et le
cas échéant être testés
de la même manière l'application vous
permettra vous préviendra pardon si l'un
de vos contacts devaient être testés
positifs mais de manière anonyme vous ne
saurez jamais qui était le contact en
question la logique vous l'aurez compris
est la même que celle des équipes d'
enquête sanitaire citée par ma collègue
christelle du boss
le résultat d'une notification positive
d'ailleurs est en ligne avec la doctrine
la doctrine relatives aux cas contacter
si vous êtes notifié vous devrez vous
isolez prendre contact avec un médecin
et le cas échéant être testés
l'urgence est en effet de couper les
départs de feu les résurgence de
l'épidémie le plus vite possible
les équipes d' enquêtes sanitaires sont
la pierre angulaire de ce combat contre
l'épidémie elles ont fait l'objet ici de
multiples débats il ya quelques semaines
elles sont notre assurance vie en
quelque sorte mais leur efficacité est
limitée par au moins deux facteurs
d'abord certains cas de transmission qui
échappe au travail des enquêteurs
sanitaires c'est le cas dans le bus ou
le métro ou lorsque vous faites la queue
au supermarché
si vous avez été un peu trop proche un
peu trop longtemps de quelqu'un de
malade testé à porte a posteriori
personne ne pourra vous prévenir la
rapidité d'intervention ensuite entre le
moment où une personne est testée
positive et celui où ces contacts sont
appelés il peut se passer plusieurs
heures voire plusieurs jours comme le
montrent de nombreux travaux
scientifiques ces heures et ses jours
sont décisifs
plus de la moitié des contaminations
sont le fait de personnes en période
d'incubation ou asymptomatiques qui donc
contaminent leurs proches et d'autres
personnes sans le savoir
dans ces conditions ce top cow vide
n'est nullement magique mais
l'application apporte une réponse à ces
difficultés
elle offre un complément utile et
nécessaire au travail central des
équipes d' enquête sanitaire
la question qui se pose c'est ces
avantages centile décisif justifit-il la
mobilisation d'autant d'efforts et de
moyens
c'est ma conviction et c'est la
conviction du gouvernement français
c'est la conviction également de la
quasi totalité des gouvernements
européens qui tous ont un projet
d'application en cours
c'est la conviction des épidémiologistes
et des médecins surtout et je veux à cet
égard rappelé les nombreux avis du
conseil scientifique le dernier daté du
20 avril qui ont estimé indispensable de
déployer un tel outil même si la
prévalence de l'épidémie était basse je
veux citer l'académie de médecine qui a
donné un avis favorable à l'utilisation
de smartphones pour le suivi du
déconfinement je veux enfin citer les
mots de pierre-yves boel de simon
cauchemez de victoria co lisa de
dominique costagliola de jean-claude
desenclos d' arnaud fontanet de carhaix
pts 2/4 à paulette aude alfred spira ou
encore d'alain jacques valeron tous
épidémiologistes reconnu au sein de nos
plus prestigieux instituts de recherche
qui comme 60 autres scientifiques et
professionnels de médecine ont affirmé
dans une tribune au monde que cette
application est un moyen parmi d'autres
mais elle est un atout incontestable
pour identifier de nombreux contacts de
façon instantanée
elle permet de gagner du temps si nous
voulons éviter une seconde crise
sanitaire
nous devons nous en donner les moyens
d'un point de vue sanitaire
l'application stop qu'ovide dûment
encadré doit faire partie d'une
stratégie nationale de contrôle de
l'épidémie fin de citation stop qu'ovide
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
n'est pas une coquetterie technologique
c'est un outil sanitaire au service de
la protection des françaises et des
français
mais je sais que cette assemblée il y
est attaché l'efficacité sanitaire ne se
paye pas de n'importe quel prix parce
que cela correspond à la culture et aux
valeurs de notre pays parce que c'est
une condition indépassable de
l'acceptation de ce top peu vite par la
population française ce qu'a rappelé
nicole belloubet ce que le gouvernement
s'est attaché à offrir pendant ce que
c'est que le gouvernement s'est attaché
à offrir le maximum de garanties en
matière de protection de la vie privée
des françaises et des français je veux à
cet égard prendre le temps de répondre
aux interrogations et aux critiques qui
ont jalonné la jeune route de cette
application
je sais les questions légitimes que
beaucoup se sont posés les projections
dystopique que ce projet a suscité à tel
point qu'il fut parfois plus simple
comme l'a fait nicole belloubet dans les
dernières semaines de commencer par dire
ce que stop que vides ne faisait pas
plus tôt que ce que l'application
faisait en quelque sorte de dessiner son
portrait en creux plutôt qu'en plein
certains craignent une société de
surveillance dénonce le tracking et la
géolocalisation demande à ceux de leurs
proches qui téléchargerait l'application
de les supprimer de la liste de leurs
contacts
je veux les rassurer de tout cela il
n'est rien
la seule technologie utilisée est celle
du bluetooth la seule information
disponible est la notification anonymes
reçues et reçu de vous seul
lorsque vous avez été en contact
prolongé avec une personne depuis testée
positive ni l'utilisation de la
géolocalisation du lac saint denis à vos
contacts ni à la liste de personnes qui
vous avez croisé nulle possibilité de
savoir de qui vient l'information pour
qui que ce soit ni pour vous ni pour les
autres ni pour l'état
toutes les informations sont cryptés
hébergé sur votre téléphone ou sur un
serveur de la direction générale de la
santé
mais sans que personne n'y est accès
d'autres évoquent le chantage la
conditionnalité le libre arbitre qui
pourrait être édulcorée par la pression
sociale
là encore ces préventions sont légitimes
mais elles sont sans objet
l'installation de l'application stop vie
des volontaires entièrement volontaire
je tiens à ce titre à rappeler que nul
ne pourra contraindre quiconque est
installé l'application faute de quoi ils
ou elles s'exposeraient potentiellement
à des poursuites judiciaires
d'autres encore évoquent l'efficacité de
l'application la nécessité d'atteindre
dit-on 60% de la population pour qu'elle
soit efficace
ceux là auront mal lu l'étude des
équipes d'oxford collège d'oxford et de
l'impérial college qui les premiers en
modéliser l'impact des outils numériques
étaient tels que stop covit ce que
disent ses études ce que disent ces
travaux c'est que dans un bassin de vie
sans autres gestes barrières la
diffusion de l'application au près de
60% de la population 56% pour être
précis suffirait à elle seule à elle
seule à juguler l'épidémie
ce que ces travaux dystocie c'est que
des lacets première activation
l'application sauf déjà des vies parce
qu'elle compense certains angles morts
des équipes des équipes d' enquête
sanitaire ce qu'elle dit enfin c'est que
son efficacité systémique et linéaire à
partir de quelques pourcents
d'activation d'autres enfin évoque les
dérives atavique des gouvernements leur
tendance pavlovienne à détourner les
technologies pour en faire des outils de
surveillance
je ne partage pas la vision déterministe
des technologies que cette approche
porte en son sein
ma conviction c'est que les nouvelles
technologies ne sont ni bonnes ni
mauvaises par essence et qu il nous
revient de bâtir les contre-pouvoirs et
les institutions qui nous protège de ces
tentations et des dérives de nos
sociétés c'est pour cette raison que la
garantie peut être la plus importante
mis sur la table par le gouvernement
c'est la transparence totale de stock co
vide c'est la publication du code de
l'application source ouverte par l'inria
qui permettra à tout informaticien de
confirmer que stop vide fait bien ce que
le gouvernement dit qu'il fait et rien
d'autre c'est aussi et je sais que c'est
un élément qui tenait à coeur au
président baré retailleau ce que vous
avez voté mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs lors des débats sur l'article
6 et ensuite l'article 11 du projet de
loi prorogeant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
à travers la création d'un comité de
liaison et de contrôle composé de
spécialistes de la santé des questions
d'éthique et du numérique mais aussi de
parlementaires
qui pourra diligenter tous les audits
nécessaires sur le serveur central afin
de vérifier que celui ci fait bien ce
que le gouvernement dit qu'il fait et
rien d'autre le décret instituant ce
nouveau comité de liaison et de contrôle
a été pris le 15 mai il précise la liste
des personnalités qui sont inclus dans
ce dans ce dans ce comité de liaison et
de contrôle et précise par ailleurs que
ce comité de liaison de contrôle a
vocation à évaluer audit et surveiller
l'ensemble des outils numériques de
traçage mis en place par le gouvernement
donc comprenant stop qu'ovide c'est bien
simple
l'intérêt du gouvernement celui des
autorités sanitaires c'est de faire la
transparence totale sur le
fonctionnement de cette application afin
que chacun soit rassuré et que son
adoption soit la plus large possible
une fois ces garanties posées
ce serait mentir mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs que d'affirmer que stop
qu'ovide échapperait à la règle qui veut
que le risque zéro n'existe pas en cela
et parce qu'il touchera potentiellement
des millions de françaises et de
français
ce n'est pas un projet anodin c'est pour
cela que nous assumons que stop loving
n'est pas un projet pourtant de paix
c'est un projet qui répond à une crise
historique sans laquelle il n'existerait
pas et au delà de laquelle il n'existera
pas celle du coffee 19 en la matière
l'alternative qui se pose à nous est
donc simple soit tout faire pour éviter
que l'épidémie ne reparte pour limiter
le nombre de nouvelles victimes pour
diminuer le risque d'un reconfirmant
notamment en déployant un tel outil
outil jugé nécessaire par les médecins
et adapté par la commission nationale
informatique et libertés dont je
rappelle encore une fois que son
utilisation ne sera que volontaire ou
alors choisir pour des raisons
politiques ou philosophiques qui sont
légitimes de priver les volontaires qui
le souhaiteraient de bénéficier de la
protection de cette application mais
dans ce cas dans ce cas accepter le
risque conséquent et pour le dire plus
crûment les contaminations
supplémentaires les malades
supplémentaires les morts
supplémentaires et le risque de
confinement supplémentaires cette
dernière formulation est crue elle est
presque violente mais elle n'en est pas
moins vrai elle n'est que ce que nous
dit la science de manière plus
statistiques mais moins cruel et je vous
invite à cet égard à lire les travaux
des épidémiologistes paru encore hier si
l'on refuse de se doter de tous les
outils alors il faut le faire les yeux
ouverts comme de la marguerite source
art la question qui se pose à nous qui
se pose ce soir à vous tiens donc en un
seul terme celui de la proportionnalité
la politique le droit à la vie tout est
affaire de proportionnalité ce qui
compte c'est l' équilibre et cette
question qui est en balance quel plus
gros risques sanitaires sociales
économiques voire démocratique que la
perspective du rpt confinement c'est
cette proportionnalité qui a conduit le
comité national pilote d' éthique du
numérique au sein du comité national
consultatif d'éthique a insisté sans
délai sur l'importance que représente la
mise en place d'une application de suivi
numérique de contact dont le contrôle
souverain puisse elle garantit aux
citoyens français voire européen dès
lors qu'il aura été statué sur ses
qualités éthiques
c'est cette proportionnalité encore qui
a conduit la commission nationale
informatique et libertés qui s'est
prononcé deux fois sur l'application a
estimé on ne peut plus clairement je
cite que l'application peut être
déployée conformément aux rg qui est
je le rappelle le régime de gestion des
données personnelles le plus protecteur
au monde
c'est cette proportionnalité enfin qui
conduit le gouvernement à recourir à
requérir aujourd'hui votre approbation
sur le déploiement de l'application
stop&go vide je voudrais avant d'en
terminer mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs partager avec vous une
réflexion personnelle qui dépasse le
sujet de la seule application qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui une réflexion qui
concerne plus largement l'avenir de
notre pays
car s'il ya bien une caractéristique de
ce top vite que je souhaiterais
souligner devant vous c'est bien qu'il
s'agit d'un projet français qui a le
goût de l'excellence mais aussi du
panache d'aucuns diraient de
l'entêtement qui caractérise notre pays
il a bien sûr des échos et des
ramifications européenne mais ne nous y
trompons pas ce qui tiendra demain dans
une petite icône sur chaque téléphone
est le fruit de milliers d'heures de
travail et deux nuits courtes dans ce
qui aura été un projet emblématique de
ce que ça faire les chercheurs les
industriels et les entrepreneurs
français 22 pays ont à ce jour choisi de
développer une solution de protection
des contacts qui s'appuie sur
l'interface développée par apple et
google
22 pays dont beaucoup d'européens mais
pas la france ni le royaume-uni qui
peut-être par hasard sont aussi les deux
seuls pays européens à disposer de leur
propre appareil de se dissuasion
nucléaire ce qui est finalement l'acsm
et de la souveraineté nationale
ce refus n'est pas un refus dogmatique
il n'intervient pas en soi parce qu'il
s'agit d'apple et de google
mais parce qu'une grande entreprise
aussi performante soit elle aussi
innovante soit elle n'a pas à
contraindre les choix de politique
sanitaire d'une nation souveraine
et parce que pour garantir la sécurité
des données des français l efficacité
sanitaire du dispositif la france a fait
le choix de l'indépendance
nous ne sommes pas loin s'en faut au
bout du chemin et vous pourriez dur est
décidé que ce chemin s'arrête là mais je
veux savoir à ce stade une pensée pour
toutes les équipes qui rompt en un temps
record permis cette indépendance ce qui
est déjà une victoire technique et
politique
ce projet aura été menée de main de
maître par inria et l'équipe resserrée
qui s'est engagé autour d'elle
capgemini dassault systèmes lui nabi
studio orange wheezing sans oublier tous
les autres industriels qui ont choisi de
travailler gratuitement à ce projet sans
oublier non plus la ns il a dit nul
l'inserm l'institut pasteur santé
publique france ou encore l'armée de
terre qui aura mis à disposition ses
soldats pour mener à bien les tests de
ces derniers jours qu'ils en soient
remerciés
cette aventure n'est pas terminée si
vous en décider ainsi le plus dur
commence quand même à partir de mardi
prochain
elle continue aussi au plan technique
puisque nous travaillons au déploiement
d'un support hors téléphone pour pouvoir
équiper à partir de cet été les
personnes qui n'en possède pas ou sont
éloignés du numérique cette attention à
la fracture du numérique à la fracture
numérique qui je sais est un sujet qui
tient à coeur à cette assemblée
elle a guidé l'équipe projet depuis le
début elle nous a conduit à travailler
jusqu'au bout pour rendre ce top cow
vide le plus simple possible accessibles
au plus grand nombre et notamment aux
personnes en situation de handicap
mais à l'heure où le monde du numérique
le monde tout court parfois temps à être
dominé par une poignée d'entreprises
quasi oligopolistique c'est cette même
alliance de la recherche des grandes
entreprises des start up et des
institutions qui doit permettre à la
france de tirer son épingle du jeu et de
conserver son indépendance sanitaires et
technologiques
cette histoire et cette relation à la
technologie qui est aussi à la
technologie pardon et aux sciences
plongent profondément ses racines dans
notre histoire dans le roman national
français celui de lavoisier de marie
curie des frères lumière ou de louis
pasteur celui de l'indépendance et de la
souveraineté nationale qui s'est noué
dans les choix qui furent ceux du
général de gaulle immuablement projet
j'ai prolongé par ceux qui lui ont
succédé
celui d'une modernité qui a longtemps
transcender les différences partisanes
je vous remercie c'est lui d'une martine
des redites et ça va vous plaire
monsieur le président keller qui a
longtemps transcender les différences
partisanes de la modernisation libéral
au progrès et à l'émancipation qu'il
permet inscrit au coeur du récit
historique de la gauche
cette histoire n'en perdait pas le fil
le progrès aujourd'hui n'a plus eu bonne
presse des ogm à la 5 g de l'individu
l'intelligence artificielle aux cellules
cartes et une partie de la france n'ose
plus regarder l'innovation en face
sondage après sondage
le pessimisme semble gagner du terrain
la science recul
au rythme où les fausses informations
elles et prophète autoproclamé progresse
bien sûr le réchauffement climatique est
là pour nous rappeler chaque jour que le
progrès n'est pas bon en soi et qu'il
doit être maîtrisée et piloter mais un
pays qui a peur d'innover qui se défie
de ceux qui ceux de qui se défie de ceux
qui prennent ce risque qui fait du
principe de précaution
l'alpha et l'oméga de tous ces débats
c'est un pays qui gère son déclin il est
rare
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
défendre autant un projet d'y travailler
aussi ardemment tout en espérant du fond
du coeur qu'il ne sera pas utile et que
l'épidémie finira avec l'été
mais l'espoir n'a jamais fait une
stratégie notre responsabilité c'est de
faire en sorte que tous les outils
puisse être déployée dès lors qu'ils
respectent nos valeurs pour mieux
combattre l'épidémie
c'est pourquoi je vous demande sans
jamais penser qu'il ya là une solution
magique mais assurément une solution
utile nécessaire de nous autoriser à
déployer l'application stop que vides je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
du débat la parole est maintenant aux
orateurs des groupes
monsieur philippe adnot pour 3 minutes
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur et madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
chacun ici connaît mon esprit
d'indépendance absolue ma volonté
farouche de ne pas laisser réduire notre
espace de liberté et donc l'utilisation
des technologies pour faire du traçage
numérique est pour nous une remise en
cause de nos libertés fondamentales
vous savez aussi que même si j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour nos amis
chinois
le modèle qui consiste à la
reconnaissance faciale l'attribution de
points pour bon comportement et cetera
n'est pas le modèle que je souhaite pour
notre pays pour autant j'ai suivi avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les développements de
votre projet d'application stop&go vide
car je pense que ne peut pas nier par
ailleurs la nécessité de sortir au plus
vite et dans les meilleures conditions
de cette pandémie qui a déjà fait
beaucoup de dégâts je regrette
profondément que le projet qui
regroupait 135 chercheurs de huit pays
européens est à choper sur l'opposition
centralisation décentralisation invoquée
par nos amis suisses
l'irruption des sociétés apple et google
qui se sont alliées sur le sujet d'une
manière un peu improbable mais sûrement
pas innocente
j'en suis certain a contribué à faire
voler en éclats le consensus européen
j'approuve donc la volonté du
gouvernement de faire en sorte qu' il ne
puisse pas s'approprier encore un peu
plus nos données j'espère donc que les
talents que vous avez réuni autour de
l'inria dans le cadre d'un partenariat
public privé nous permettront d'avoir
une application dans laquelle nous
pouvons avoir confiance mais qui devra
aussi réussir l'interopérabilité dans
avec les pays européens
dans la mesure où vous serez en capacité
de nous garantir la limitation dans le
temps de cette appli stock co vide dans
la mesure où vous pouvez nous garantir
que cette technologie reposera sur le
vantard y est
et l'anonymat des personnes dans la
mesure où cette pratique sera assorti
d'une politique de tests massive
indispensable qui n'a pas encore été
pratiquée jusqu'à présent je voterai
favorablement pour que vous puissiez
mettre en oeuvre cette technologie car
l'essentiel est que nous puissions
sortir rapidement de cette pandémie dont
nous n'avons pas fini de payer les
dégâts humains sociaux et économiques
mais soyez en certains vous serez en
liberté surveillée car la contrepartie
sera une exigence de respect des
engagements et une exigence sans faille
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
eliane assassi pour cinq minutes de même
le présidente
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres collègues vous voici donc nous
voici donc finalement amené à débattre
ou plutôt à donner notre avis et a
procédé à un vote sur un dispositif au
parcours quelque peu chaotique
un premier débat avait été annoncée fin
avril repoussée in extremis par edouard
philippe jugeant que l'application stop
kobe n'était pas assez prête pour être
présentés elle est telle aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre vous affirmer que
son déploiement commencerait dès ce
week-end en attendant le feu vert du
parlement
mais monsieur le ministre soyons francs
quelle valeur accordez vous au vote du
sénat repos n'est-il pas à symbolique
restera-t-il comme celui sur le plan de
déconfinement lettre morte car la
réalité est que nous n'avons pas notre
mot à dire puisque la validation déjà
acquise par la majorité gouvernementale
à l'assemblée nationale vous suffit pour
clore le parcours semé d'embûches de
cette application un renoncement à sa
mise en oeuvre aurait été préférable
d'autant que même si vous vous montrez
catégorique quant aux précautions prises
en matière de respect des libertés
publiques
il n'en demeure pas moins que de
nombreuses questions d'ordre éthique
d'ordre politique mais aussi techniques
subis subsistent
et surtout l'inquiétude est grande selon
nous en ce qui concerne la dérive
idéologique emprunté avec ce genre de
dispositif numérique
pour ce qui est des difficultés
techniques on peut s'interroger sur la
technologie bluetooth choisi qui tout en
permettant d'éviter la géolocalisation
pose quand même de nombreux problèmes de
sécurité
selon les spécialistes cette technologie
est une véritable passoire maillon
faible des smartphones par lequel les
pirates peuvent pénétrer nos mobiles par
ailleurs alors que vous estimez avoir eu
l'assentiment de la cnil qui pour sa
part a effectivement noté le respect des
principes fondamentaux fondamentaux vous
omettez de relever une des failles
soulevé dans son avis rendu public cette
semaine
en l'état du projet de décret car nous
n'avons pas à cette heure la totalité du
dossier
la commission estime que les droits
d'accès d'effacement ou d'opposition ne
s'applique pas or ils le devraient dès
lors que le traitement est basé sur le
volontariat
comment allez-vous remédier à ce défaut
technique majeur d'autant que d'autres
failles sont à craindre si l'on en croit
la chercheuse de l'inria and canto
auditionné ce matin par la commission
culture du sénat en temps normal une
telle application est développé en cinq
ans ici en trois mois quelles que soient
les ressources mobilisées
il y aura des failles bien sûr et elle
n'est pas la seule à l'affirmer dans la
même veine un collectif de chercheurs
spécialisé en cryptographie rappel sur
leurs sites relatifs au traçage
numérique un principe essentiel en
sécurité informatique
l'innocuité d'un système ne doit en
aucun cas être présumé en comptant sur
l'honnêteté de certains de ses acteurs
il alerte sur le fait qu'outre les
pouvoirs publics
d'autres acteurs collectifs ou
individuels seront tirer profit des
propriétés de ces systèmes comme autant
de failles et mettre à mal donc les
libertés individuelles
en outre parmi les craintes de
glissements subissent l'idée paradoxale
que l' usage d'une application pourrait
être volontaire mais que son nom usage
pourrez également vous être repousse
reprocher alors dites moi quel usage en
feront par exemple tel ou tel employeur
ou organismes privés et quid alors du
consentement de ses visées ceux qui se
verraient et vert est fortement incitée
à l'installer j'en viens donc aux
questions éthiques l'implication de
grands groupes privés dans la mise en
oeuvre de l'application et demain dans
son développement n'est pas pour nous
assurer sans parler des bénéfices que
cela générera par voie publicitaire pour
les cafards incontournable sur le marché
ainsi dans une tribune au monde du 27
avril
trois spécialistes du numérique alerter
sur l'ombre d'intérêts privés et
politique qui pèserait sur le projet
stop qu'ovide je cite le modèle de
gouvernance qui accompagnera sopkowitz
sera manifestement centre et dans les
mains d'une poignée d'acteurs et à
étatiques et marchands une telle
verticalité n'offrent aucune garantie
contre l'évolution rapide de
l'application en un outil coercitif
imposer à tout le monde fin de citation
alors vous vous appuyez aujourd'hui sur
les demandes des médecins
épidémiologistes qui seraient tous
favorables au développement de cette
application je pourrais vous en citer
qui y sont opposés mais le parlement est
seul juge de la défense des libertés
publiques et en outre il aurait mieux
valu s'appuyer sur l'avis des savons des
sachants avant et pendant la crise
concernant les moyens des hôpitaux
cette application n'assure pas l'
équilibre entre liberté individuelle et
efficacité sanitaires elle ouvre la voie
à des usages futurs et à l'adoption de
dispositifs très intrusif nous sommes
face au risque de créer un précédent
ce qui paraît acceptable pour stop covit
sera le sera demain dans d'autres
domaines et pour d'autres finalités
lesquelles la nuit à nous le dira mais
pour l'heure et pour notre part nous ne
seront définitives pas définis tu
définis qui veut vent par botteur dans
l'engrenage redoutable d'une
surveillance généralisée qui sera
activée avec le lancement d'un tel
dispositif est vraiment mesdames les
ministres et monsieur le ministre nous
sommes résolument opposés à ce projet
qui nous est présenté
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
emmanuel capus pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
traçage pistage suivi des contacts
historique des rencontres signalement
des contaminations à ses mots certains
ont pu se demander si big brother
n'étaient pas en train de faire son
entrée dans le domaine de la santé
et je les comprends si l'intitulé de
notre débat vise les innovations
numériques dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie il n'aura échappé à personne
que la star en la matière c'est bien
l'application stop qu'ovide sa
pertinence ces risques et son
fonctionnement ont fait couler beaucoup
d'encre 2.16 peau cristallise les débats
la teinte possible aux libertés
individuelles et l'efficacité sanitaires
d'une telle application
à l'ère du traçage numérique il est
parfaitement compréhensible et peut-être
même sein d'une application visant à
retracer les rencontres entre les
individus suscite des interrogations
plusieurs pays plus ou moins
démocratique travail à des dispositifs
plus ou moins liberticide
certains avec une géolocalisation des
individus d'autres en imposant
l'installation de l'application
certains encore en s'en remettant à
google et à apple
le gouvernement a fait l'effort malgré
les pressions de développer une solution
française en refusant d'accroître la
dépendance de la france à l'égard des
gars femmes
nous espérons qu'il s'agit là des
premiers pas vers la souveraineté
numérique
si essentiel à nos yeux la proche en
code source ouvert nous semble également
être une bonne idée
elle permettra deux choses d'abord de
vérifier que l'application est conforme
aux annonces et ensuite d'augmenter le
niveau de sécurité de l'application il
faudra veiller en particulier à ce que
personne n'ait accès aux identifiants
des malades ou à des cas contacts et à
ce que personne ne soit contraint
d'installer l'application
nous nous réjouissons que le
gouvernement soit par
à proposer en un temps très court une
solution qui est probablement la plus
respectueuse possible des libertés la
cnil a rendu hier un nouvel avis sur la
question en indiquant que ces
recommandations avaient été entendus
elle a précisé à cette occasion que la
création de ce top coville avait
respecté le concept dit de protection
des données dès la conception
certains ont déploré cette approche
libérale en faisant rimer autorités avec
efficacité mais nous ne devons pas
sacrifier les principes qui sont les
nôtres les libertés individuelles sont
essentiels à notre démocratie
elles ne sont pas une option si les
restrictions apparaissent nécessaires
nous devons veiller à ce qu'elles soient
les plus limité possible la
responsabilité des individus auxquels
notre groupe croît beaucoup implique
d'ailleurs que ces derniers disposent de
leur liberté de choix
aussi si elle n'est pas obligatoire
stop go vide est elle encore utile
études à l'appui
nous avons entendu des voix s'élever
pour affirmer qu'elle serait en fait
dépourvue d'effets nous n'avons pas de
telles certitudes vous avez mesdames et
monsieur le ministre rappelait les
situations dans lesquelles les
enquêteurs sanitaires sont démunis c'est
notamment le cas des zones urbaines
denses mais aussi les transports communs
en commun nous ne connaissons pas
l'identité des personnes que nous
croisons dans la rue et c'est heureux
nous ne savons pas avec qui nous
voyageons dans les trains et les métros
impossible donc de les prévenir si nous
tombons malades les enquêteurs sanitaire
ne le pourront pas non plus à ce jour
seule une application permet de remédier
à ces cas de figure les garanties
apportées par le gouvernement nous
semble suffisamment solide nous serons
de cependant très attentifs à
l'utilisation de ce top cow vide
la technologie n'est pas une panacée
elle est utile dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
mais elle ne nous dispenserons elle mais
elle ne nous dispensera jamais de
l'humain nous sommes ainsi
particulièrement vigilant quant aux
moyens dont disposent les enquêteurs
sanitaires il est indispensable qu'il
soit suffisamment nombreux pour
retrouver et accompagner l'ensemble des
personnes susceptibles d'avoir été
infectés
la france continue de vivre
avec le risque de qu'ovide dès lors
qu'ils contreviennent qu'il ne
contreviennent pas à nos principes
tous les outils qui contribueront à
faire reculer le virus bénéficieront du
soutien du groupe les indépendants mes
chers collègues la pire des privations
de liberté que nous ayons connue c'est
le confinement les outils qu'ils
pourront éviter dans le respect de nos
principes démocratiques
un nouveau confinement bénéficieront
donc de du soutien du groupe les
indépendants merci la parole est
maintenant monsieur loïc hervé pour sept
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat madame la garde des
sceaux madame et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues le débat et le vote
de ce soir n'ont d'existence que par la
seule volonté de l'exécutif de consulter
le parlement sur la mise en place d'une
application numérique de traçage sociale
appelée stop qu'ovide ce débat et ce
vote revêt à mes yeux un caractère
beaucoup plus politique et philosophique
que technique et juridique
si on ne peut négliger le contexte dans
lequel nous débattons alors qu'un virus
a tué trente mille de nos compatriotes
et mis notre économie à genoux
on doit toujours être vigilant de ne pas
passer d'une société de la bienveillance
à une société la surveillance monsieur
le ministre je ne méconnais ni votre
bonne foi ni aucun des efforts fournis
pour rendre cette appli conforme au
droit national et communautaire en
tenant compte des deux avis de la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés je sais aussi que vous vous
employez à rassurer ceux qui comme moi
ont de fortes réserves sur ce dispositif
mais ici au parlement notre république
là où s'exprime la volonté populaire
je vais vous dire tout simplement que
lorsque je fais rationnellement le
calcul coût avantage de cette
application
je lui trouve tellement de défaut et si
peu de mérite qu'il m'est impossible
comme un certain nombre de membres de
mon groupe de vous donner notre accord
tout d'abord sur le plan des principes
je combats fermement cette idée du
solutio nisme technologique à tout crin
qui peut voir les principes de
protection de la vie privée comme des
freins aux progrès qui peut même
s'accommoder d'atteindre aux libertés
publiques pour satisfaire une cause
aussi noble que celle de la santé
publique
et puis il ya les sous-entendus de
l'économie qui dans cet hémicycle
mes chers collègues n'a pas déjà entendu
dans la bouche de tel ou tel que la loi
78 la cnil ou leur gpd sont des
contraintes trop lourde qui empêche la
croissance de la nouvelle économie qui
n'a jamais entendu que notre cadre
législatif français et européen nous
priver de toute perspective de gagner
dans la concurrence internationale
monsieur le ministre vous nous demandiez
ce matin en commission des lois
quel pourrait être le gain politique
recherchée dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette application
à la lumière de ce que je viens de vous
dire je me pose aussi la question mais
je suis sûr de ne pas apporter les mêmes
réponses que vous ensuite en termes de
temporalité si cette application avait
dû être mises en oeuvre
en toute logique elle aurait dû l'être
comme un outil du confinement au moment
même où nombre de nos libertés étaient
si lourdement atteinte liberté d'aller
et de venir liberté du commerce et
d'industrie droite votent ce qui aurait
pu être une application de confinement
est mis en oeuvre environ un mois après
le début du déconfinement ce qui lui
donne beaucoup moins déficiences alors
que l'on sait que l'acceptabilité
sociale risque d'être trop faible et je
veux relayé ici
l'inquiétude de certains maires ou
présidents de collectivités locales qui
s'étonne qu'on évoque un consensus de
leur association
à ce stade du débat enfin je ne peux pas
passer sous silence la question de la
souveraineté numérique
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
annoncé il ya quelques semaines une
application souveraine européenne
on nous a vanté le travail collaborative
entre l'inria en france a frôlé
l'infarctus shaft en allemagne et
l'école polytechnique fédérale de
lausanne en suisse
l'argument était particulièrement
vendeur et convaincant et je me suis
même demandé comment je pourrais ne pas
soutenir une telle initiative qui
unissait les instituts de recherche
publics européens les plus réputés à
l'instant où l'on se parle
il n'en reste plus rien les choix
nationaux chez certains de nos voisins
les ont fait abandonner ce projet commun
pour aller vers des applications
décentralisée souvent reprenant le
système proposé par l'application promu
par apple et google
quel renoncement quand on sait que les
systèmes ne sont pas ou sont
difficilement intéropérables est un
frontalier qui vous le dit et comment ne
pas citer ici et maintenant
les exemples mondiaux mondiaux d'abandon
et d'échecs relatifs à des applications
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs plus ou moins
proche du projet que nous vous nous
présenter ce soir
cette application permet grâce à la
crise sanitaire de franchir deux lignes
rouges à mes yeux
la première est l'expérimentation
massive une application de traçage
social avec la construction d'une
architecture numérique centralisée la
seconde est le fait que les plus grands
acteurs du numérique mondiale ce soit
allié sur un sujet pour mettre leurs
moyens en commun leur application
fonctionnera par défaut dans leur
système d'exploitation de leur appareil
qu'il s'agisse de smartphones ou de
montres connectés nous ne sommes qu'au
début d'un basculement et des digues
auront pu naturellement les nouvelles
fonctionnalités offertes ouvriront le
champ à d'autres finalités et même si
les garanties apparemment apportées sont
nombreuses et monsieur le ministre
madame mesdames les ministres j'en ai
bien conscience sachez le
elles ne sont finalement que très mineur
par rapport aux pas de géant que stop
qu'ovide risque de nous faire franchir
le curseur qui devrait davantage bouger
entre lacs la liberté la responsabilité
est en train de bouger entre la liberté
la sécurité
alors parce que je sais bien que l'enfer
est toujours pavé de des meilleures
attentions
j'oserais pour conclure avec étienne de
la boétie dans son discours de la
servitude volontaire
ouvrez les guillemets il est incroyable
de voir comme le peuple dès qu'il est
assujetti
tombe soudain dans la ssi profond oublie
de sa liberté qui lui est impossible de
se réveiller pour la reconquérir
il sert si bien et si volontiers qu'on
dirait à le voir qu'il n'a pas seulement
perdu sa liberté mais bien gagner sa
servitude
fin de citation pour moi et pour un
certain nombre de mots de mon groupe
stop qu'ovide c'est non merci chers
collègues de la parole est maintenant au
président bruno retailleau
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues tant que nous n'aurons pas
vaincu cette épidémie tant que nous
n'aurons pas un vaccin
donc on n'aura pas un traitement
absolument décisif la lutte contre le
virus devra concentrer ses efforts et
ses moyens sur la façon dont on peut
casser les reins de cette épidémie
c'est la raison pour laquelle et dès le
début du confinement je l'avais souvent
appelé au gouvernement il faut cette
stratégie du dépistage du traçage et de
l' isolement c'est la stratégie gagnante
de tous les pays qui ont obtenu de
meilleurs résultats que notre propre
pays au sein de ce triptyque le traçage
est essentiel parce que lorsqu'une
personne tombe malade il est fondamental
de pouvoir retrouver pour les alerter
celles et ceux qu'elle a pu croiser et
possiblement évidemment contaminés c'est
absolument essentiel et c'est dans ce
cadre que le gouvernement nous soumet un
nouvel outil un outil digital
complémentaire de celui que nous avons
voté à l'article 6 vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur ministre dans la loi de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'était il ya seulement
quelques jours
cette application est évidemment elle a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre et beaucoup
de sueur je salue moi aussi les
entreprises françaises qui bénévolement
ont participé à la mise au point
d'applications et c'était difficile et
je le sais je les suivis de près je
pense qu'il faut éviter deux écueils qui
me semblent tous les deux parfaitement
excessif d'un côté la technologie est le
remède c'est la panacée
celso luccioni sme technologies
ça n'est absolument pas mon parti et de
l'autre côté le remède c'est pire que le
mal au nom des libertés publiques
je pense que nous n'avons pas à choisir
mes chers collègues entre d'un côté la
liberté de l'autre côté le sanitaire
nous sommes des législateurs et en
permanence ça avait été le cas aussi au
moment du terrorisme nous devons trouver
ce juste équilibre
je le préfère au mot de proportionnalité
entre l'une et l'autre nous n'avons le
droit et le devoir de n'écarter aucune
solution si cette solution permet de
lutter contre une épidémie est de sauver
des vies mais pas au prix bien sûr de
renier ce que nous sommes et notre
propre valeurs démocratiques et
républicaines
il ya deux mois c'est le 8 avril s'était
pas hier j'ai écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander de thil de
46 la réponse n'est parvenue ces
dernières heures mais je sais qu'il ya
loin de l'olympe à la terre les deux
types de garanties c'était d'abord le
premier type des garanties d'efficacité
et ensuite des garanties sur les
libertés
elles étaient au nombre de quatre
l'anonymisation le volontariat je
comprends c'était confirmé notamment par
la cnil qu' il y un libre consentement
dans toutes les étapes du téléchargement
à la notification
jamais l'état ne devra connaître la
liste des personnes contaminées
jamais l'état ne pourrait connaître la
liste des interactions sociales
ensuite bien sûr le caractère temporaire
avec des mécanismes d'auto destruction
législatives pour l'application
mécanique 14 jours pour les donnez vous
à desquels elle s'auto détruire ont
ensuite la transparence j'ai toujours
réclamée et dans ce courrier aux prises
en république je lui disais il faut un
code source ouvert pour qu'il puisse
être discuté débattu pour que
d'éventuelles failles
là aussi puissent être dépistés et c'est
le cas et enfin il faut un
contre-pouvoir oui vous l'avez indiqué
avec philippe bas et d'autres j'ai
beaucoup insisté
je pense que les clubs
contrôler les contre-pouvoirs c'est
essentiel on ne déploiera les nouvelles
technologies que si nous sommes en
mesure de renforcer les moyens de
contrôle et contre-pouvoirs à la mesure
de la puissance de cette technologie
c'est important de le rappeler et nous
le vérifierons avec la commission
évidemment des lois puis y avait les
garanties d'efficacité 1
est ce que ça marche notamment avec
l'univers apple ça semble fonctionner 2
est ce que ce sera utile parce que c'est
vrai cela vient tard bien sûr
est ce que sera sera utile parce que est
ce qu'il y aura suffisamment de
téléchargements aujourd'hui 60% des
français s'y montrent favorables mais
49% pensent qu'ils pourraient
télécharger
je pense que ce sera beaucoup beaucoup
moins mais quand on connaît un peu
l'épidémiologie un peu vaut mieux que
rien du tout surtout lorsque il faut
briser les reins de cette épidémie au
bout du bout je pense que ici dans cet
hémicycle
je n'ai jamais fait preuve de
complaisance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
et quand il fallait assumer la critique
je les assume et sans ménager les
ministres je voudrais vous dire monsieur
le ministre
ici pourquoi au delà des doutes qu'il
est légitime d'avoir j'ai choisi avec
que beaucoup de membres très
majoritairement de mon groupe de
soutenir cette application de lui donner
une chance
je pense que les cartes et c'est prendre
le risque d'oublier des moyens et
notamment digitaux de lutter contre
l'épidémie mais c'est pire c'est prendre
un risque qui est le risque pour moi du
renoncement de la soumission comme l'a
fait l'allemagne l'italie sans doute
l'espagne peut-être et d'autres pays la
soumission aux gars femmes c'est ce qui
nous menace et pour moi la raison la
plus forte
la première c'est celle de la
souveraineté numérique on parle en
permanence actuellement depuis la crise
de la souveraineté qui se décline dans
tous les domaines mes chers collègues si
vous ne voulez pas de traces et
géolocalisées surtout n'utilisez pas
votre iphone ou votre smartphone
l'application tel qu'on nous la propose
la cnil de rappelait est autrement plus
protectrice vraiment sincèrement
objectivement ce que je veux dire
pour terminer définitivement c'est que
ne rien faire ne rien tenter par nous
mêmes avec nos entreprises se seraient
écartés une solution française une
solution j'espère demain j'y crois
encore européenne mais ce serait surtout
abdiqué abdiqué notre statut de citoyen
pour un statut médiocre de consommateurs
dociles
ma chère catherine d'une colonie
numérique américaine
ce sera aussi renoncer un modèle madame
belloubet vous l'avez rappelé notre
modèle français des tic des tic
numérique depuis 1978 notre modèle
européen qui a pu concilier qui a pu
rendre compatible une approche
technologique avec une approche
personnalisée respectueuse aussi bien
des données personnelles que de la vie
privée il privacy notamment rgp des etc
etc
c'est ce qui condense ce que nous sommes
ce que nous voulons être dans nos
civilisations le respect absolu de la
personne monsieur le ministre je vous ai
combattu j'ai combattu plutôt la loi via
et je suis fier que mon groupe
vous savez les déférer au conseil
communal parce que je pensais qu'il
fallait qu'on préserve notre
indépendance vis-à-vis des moyens de
censure et bien c'est aussi aujourd'hui
au nom de mon groupe
au nom de cette indépendance que je veux
donner sa chance à une application
française qui peut être utile je ne sais
pas dans quelle mesure mais qui
pourraient l'être aujourd'hui ou demain
parce qu'on ne veut pas si jamais il y
avait des résurgences et pour d'autres
épidémies se précipiter si nous n'avons
encore rien anticipé si l'avant toujours
un temps de retard
nous ne voulons pas céder aux sirènes
des gaffes à messi dans attention
merci monsieur le président
la parole est maintenant monsieur jérôme
durain pour sept minutes 10 dans
monsieur le ministre
le groupe socialiste a suivi avec
intérêt vos prises de parole que ce soit
au parlement dans la presse ou à travers
les différents documents transmis aux
parlementaires
nous vous en remercions et nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà noter que le débat sur
cette question sensible se déroule au
moins dans cette assemblée dans un
climat plutôt apaisé
l'épidémie de vide a vu se dérouler de
nombreux débats moins serein ces
dernières semaines aussi je tâcherai
pour éviter ces écueils de ne pas
exprimer de position trop dogmatique
concernant le destin de cette
application stop évident que vous
monsieur cedrico vous êtes chargé de
nous vanter la solution vous nous
proposez poursuit des objectifs utile et
il faudrait être de mauvaise foi pour
affirmer que rien n'est fait pour
résoudre les différentes problématiques
à laquelle elle est confrontée
je vais essayer d'aborder plusieurs des
dilemmes qui se sont présentés à vous
vous avez fait des choix techniques
discutable et ses choix ne peuvent pas
tous être balayées d'un revers de la
main par exemple architecture
centralisée ou données décentralisée sur
les téléphones des utilisateurs je ne
suis pas spécialiste de sécurité
informatique
mais on peut comprendre que ces deux
écoles ont des arguments en leur faveur
vous avez retenu une stature centralisée
suffisamment sécurisé d'après vous nous
pouvons entendre
même s'il subsiste des doutes sérieux
sur l'inviolabilité du fichier
centralisé par ailleurs la solution
décentralisée permet souvent de créer
plus de confiance chez les utilisateurs
ce débat c'est celui qui vous a fait
perdre la participation qui n'est pas
anecdotique de nos voisins allemands et
ce n'est pas à vous que je vais
apprendre l'exigence de nos voisins
allemands en matière de protection des
données
si le protocole robert était un embryon
de coopération européenne nous
regrettons vivement que la france se
retrouve defacto isolé en retenant une
solution peu populaire chez vos ses
voisins cela a des implications pour nos
compatriotes qui souhaiteraient utiliser
un tel dispositif lors de déplacements à
l'étranger
deuxième exemple le gps
tous le choix du bluetouff peut se
justifier ne pas avoir retenu le gps
présente des avantages sur la
géolocalisation des personnes mais tous
ceux qui utilisent du matériel bluetouff
par exemple dans leur voiture savent à
quel point cette technologie
cette mise en route peut être aléatoire
est faillible certains évoquent un
chiffre de 80%
concernant la sécurité des données
centralisée je veux bien entendre que
d'autres fichiers seraient moins bien
protégés mais je ne sais pas si cela
suffit à me rassurer même si je tiens à
saluer la démarche que vous avez
entreprises de soumettre votre solution
un bug bounty vial annecy revenons sur
la question centrale des libertés
fondamentales
nous sommes peut-être un tournant de la
société la vidéosurveillance les écoutes
téléphoniques le tracking
notre monde est aujourd'hui fondées sur
une méfiance généralisée entre les
individus
nous avons aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'aller encore plus loin si ce n'est
trop loin une application dont on ne
sait pas si elle sera utile des drones
qui volent sans y être autorisé des
attestations de sortie je n'ai ni mère
pas plus loin
je connais le contexte sanitaire chers
collègues mais il faut savoir dire stop
et je crains qu'avec que les collègues
de mon groupe nous ne soyons obligés de
dire stop à ce top cow vide certes
l'avis rendu par la cnil n'a pas été
aussi tranchée que certains opposants à
votre projet l'attendait et vous
l'utilisez habilement dans vos
démonstrations pour autant la cnil ne
vous donne pas de blanc seing la cnil
note que l'application utilisera un
service de cap chat qui permet de
vérifier lors de l'installation que
l'application est utilisé par un être
humain et que ces services sera dans un
premier temps fourni par un service
tiers susceptible d'entraîner la
collecte de données personnelles non
prévu dans le décret ou des transferts
de données hors de l'union européenne
elle recommande donc la cnil des
développements ultérieurs de
l'application qui permettent rapidement
l'utilisation d'une technologie
alternative et il a été découvert dans
le code source que vous avez continué de
rendre public que c'est bien google qui
fournit l'outil captcha mais je
reviendrai sur l'avis de la cnil plus
tard j'aimerais maintenant évoquer
quelques éléments de comparaison
internationale je comprends que les
choix qui ont été faits sont différents
de ceux qui ont été vus en corée par
exemple mais j'aimerais revenir sur la
situation de ce pays
pour ceux qui nous apprend d utiliser
sion non prévus des applications
j'imagine que personne n'avait envisagé
en corée quand foyers soient scrutés à
l'aune de l'orientation sexuelle des
individus qu'ils fréquentent nous ne
pouvons pas savoir qui aura la volonté
de faire fuiter telle ou telle
concentration de contact bluetouff dans
quelques mois autre exemple à 5
asiatique à singapour pays discipline et
20% seulement des habitants
on peut télécharger l'application
exemples européens l'autriche ou une
application a été développée et
télécharger seulement cinq cent mille
fois pour 8 8 millions d'habitants
les autrichiens nous disent que ça ne
sert à rien finalement et qu'ils se
débrouillent très bien avec les brigades
humaine la cnil dit dans son avis qu'il
faudra évaluer l'efficacité de
l'application
après son lancement mais monsieur le
ministre nous aimerions en être
convaincu avant nos concitoyens ne vont
pas rejeter votre solution parce qu'ils
craignent pour leurs données
personnelles
on peut le regretter d'ailleurs mais
aujourd'hui nos données personnelles
sont déjà trop accessible pour des
raisons commerciales
j'espère d'ailleurs que nous serons à
l'avenir aussi exigeant avec les gars
femmes que nous le sommes en ce moment
avec vous mais nos concitoyens ne sont
pas là pour la plupart il ya bien des
militants hectares et des libertés
fondamentales qui protestent avec raison
contre cette initiative publique qui
constitue effectivement un précédent
mais la réalité c'est que la majorité de
nos concitoyens
elle considère que cette application
arrive bien trop tard et ne changera
rien si j'osais monsieur le président je
demanderai un scrutin public auprès de
mes collègues pour savoir qui ici va
installer l'application on pourrait
répondre par assis debout bulletin
secret je pense que le résultat serait
décevant aussi monsieur le ministre le
groupe socialiste attend d'entendre les
réponses qui seront apportées aux
questions qui vont vous être posée mais
d'ores et déjà je peux vous annoncer que
nous ne sommes pas convaincus
nous espérons nous tromper et que votre
application rencontrera un grand succès
la vérité c'est que nous n'y croyons pas
surtout nous ne voulons pas de fausses
promesses votre foi dans la technologie
votre dernière saillie votre dernier
élan était éloquent peut s'apparenter à
du solutia nisme technologique
nous sommes admiratifs de la compétence
de la virtuosité technologique de nos
scientifiques de nos centres de
recherche de nos industriels de l'eau
start up
nous sommes reconnaissants
de votre souci de souveraineté numérique
dans la gestion de ce dossier
mais ce n'est pas parce que nous savons
et pour pouvoir le faire que nous devons
le faire la fascination exagéré à notre
avis du nouveau monde pour la start up
nation ne doit pas nous aveugler votre
logiciel
il faudrait péter il faut le dire encore
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas ce top que vides
c'est au mieux antico vide et il ne
dispense pas des gestes barrières il ne
dispense pas non plus et il ne justifie
pas d'oublier en chemin le respect des
libertés individuelles
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à madame françoise laborde
pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames les ministres
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la pandémie ducobu 19 nous rappelle que
les crises
interroge nos consciences sur les
libertés fondamentales que nous sommes
enclins à sacrifier de manière
provisoire ou non je regrette les
conditions dans lesquelles se débat se
déroule avec la publication tardive du
décret qui encadrera stop qu'ovide la
confrontation à la communauté
informatique démarre seulement ce jour
une publication dans un délai
raisonnable aurait pu rassurer davantage
sur la détection d'éventuelles failles
de sécurité
l'expérience de la plateforme apb avec
ses 1582 violations critique détecté
lors des audits commandés par la cour
des comptes vient nourrir cette
inquiétude sur l'utilité de
l'application les épidémiologistes et la
cnil considère qu'elle peut être utile
en contribuant rapidement à briser les
chaînes de contamination le traçage des
contacts et bien à la base de
l'épidémiologie
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
accepté de voter l'article 11 de la loi
du 11 mai 2020 prorogeant l'état
d'urgence n'a ni sanitaires nettement
plus intrusif que ce top cow vide
le gouvernement s'appuie sur l'avis
favorable des épidémiologistes qui
constate un relâchement de la population
mais cela concerne une minorité
la grande majorité de nos concitoyens a
compris l'enjeu sanitaire exposés par
les multiples expos
tease diffusées par les médias en
complément de l'information fournie par
l'état ce n'est pas en les culpabilisant
que non les convaincront de consentir au
traçage pour éviter une deuxième vague
et 1re confinement la clé de la réussite
me semble être d'établir la confiance de
la population dans la décision publique
et pour cela je me satisfais du suivi
qui sera réalisé par le comité de
contrôle et de liaison koffi 19 dans un
souci de traitement et de transparence
du traitement des données sur le public
visé je regrette qu'une adaptation sous
forme de boîtier ne puisse être
disponible rapidement pour les personnes
âgées qui peuvent se retrouver exposés
dans les transports en commun les
commerces ou les ehpad
partout où les contaminations ont été
nombreuses la délibération de la cnil
rendu ce jour mme m'a rassuré validant
le dispositif quant à son utilité à sa
proportionnalité pointant toutefois des
interrogations sur l'exactitude des
données
prévoyez vous un paramétrage pour éviter
la réception par un utilisateur de
notification récurrente le conduisant à
se faire dépister excessivement la
proportionnalité d atteinte à nos
libertés individuelles s'apprécie
également par rapport à la sécurité
apportée à la préservation de nos
données personnelles
fallait-il que le traçage soient
numérisés et centralisée quel est le
devenir de ces données autant de
questions importantes
aussi je regrette que le gouvernement
ait demandé au parlement de trancher la
question
séparément alors que la cnil reconnaît
la complémentarité de ce top cow vide
avec contacts qu vide et le cidep nous
aurons donc d'un côté l'application de
l'autre les bases de données déjà voté
est nettement plus intrusive avec dans
les deux cas des enjeux de sécurité
sensibles sur l' architecture
centralisée du protocole vous affirmez
que la risque d'une dérive est faible
mais elle n'est pas nulle
la question a été soulevée dans les
états ayant choisi une architecture
décentralisée laissant la france seule
avec le royaume uni a préféré la
centralisation aucun état même
démocratique n'est à l'abri d'une dérive
qui utiliserait une telle application
pour tracer les déplacements de nos
concitoyens ce top cow vide reconnaît
reconnaissons le a fait l'objet de
garanties en matière de sécurité
anonyme à sion volontariat total
caractère temporaire déterminées par
décret exclusion de données sensibles
telles que le recensement des personnes
infectées des zones dans lesquelles les
personnes se sont déplacées suivi des
interactions sociales et non
surveillance du respect des mesures de
confinement
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
j'aurai une garantie supplémentaire à
vous demander qui va un peu plus loin
que le point 51 de l'avis de la cnil la
suppression automatique des données
figurant dans le serveur central lors de
la désinstallation l'infiltration du
numérique dans tous les pans de
l'administration et de notre vie privée
ne va pas sans danger ce n'est pas parce
qu'on ne peut pas le faire qu'on doit le
faire qu'on a le droit de le faire
ce n'est pas parce qu'on vous fait
visiter une pièce que l'on accepte de
vous donner les clés du logement pour
les innovations numériques comme pour le
reste le facteur humain demeure le
facteur central en toutes circonstances
la confiance encore est également un
élément incontournable pour garantir
l'adéquation de ses dispositifs avec nos
principes
pour conclure une partie de mon groupe
soutiendra la mise en place de ce top
cow vide
nous nous réjouissons de ce débat qui
permet au parlement comme c'est son rôle
de se prononcer en toute conscience à un
moment aussi important pour nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
merci chers collègues les paroles et
maintenant monsieur julien bargeton pour
cinq minutes mais c'est le président mes
chers collègues même mesdames et
messieurs les ministres benjamin
constant disait l'arbitraire quand il
est utilisé pour le crime n'est pas
seulement funeste quand il est utilisé
pour le crime
quand il le futile contre le crime le
contre le crime qu'il reste dangereux
donc ce qui veut dire que pour nous il
n'y a absolument pas d'arbitraire nous
ne justifie rions pas un vote ou qui
mettrait en cause les libertés publiques
ce top provident a suscité des
interrogations des doutes qui nous
semblent maintenant pouvoir être levée
parce que évidemment il touche à un
sujet qui est l' équilibre entre le
respect de la vie privée et puis
l'intérêt général et donc notamment au
nom de la santé publique
et pourquoi est ce que le curseur est au
bon endroit et bien parce que il est à
la fois temporaire anonyme et volontaire
et ses trois principes permettent de
mettre le curseur au bon endroit
premier sujet est il utile les
scientifiques nous disent qu'il est
utile et qu'il est encore
alors c'est vrai que l'avis des
scientifiques eux n'oblige pas le
parlement a voté mais dans le sens
inverse
s'il n'y avait évidemment pas ce soutien
alors nous ne serions pas là et nous
n'aurions évidemment pas notre accord
c'est donc une condition préalable qui
est rempli deuxième sujet le sujet des
libertés individuelles si chère à la
construction de l'identité politique du
sénat évidemment et qui est importante
la cnil là aussi après avoir émis des
conditions a donné son feu vert
donc le deuxième aspect qui est l'aspect
des libertés est lui aussi rempli à
partir de là on pourrait même dire que
l'état
ce n'a pas simplement le droit de mettre
en place une telle application mais
qu'il en a le devoir impérieux
il y à des recours d'ailleurs qui existe
déjà les mêmes qui critiquent serait
peut-être promptes à attaquer l'état
s'il ne mettait pas en place une telle
application avec les responsabilités qui
vont derrière
je dirais donc autant qu'un droit c'est
un devoir impérieux et puis surtout
surtout il ya un sujet extrêmement
importante
moi je me réjouis que ce cette
application souhaite développer dans un
cadre public parce que il ne faut pas
laisser aux gars femmes aux géants du
numérique le monopole sur notre bien le
plus précieux qui est le lien social qui
est la vie sociale
or apple google etc se sont déjà montrés
prêts et dans certains pays le font
et donc il ya là une forme de naïveté
quiconque qui consiste à baisser les
bras a finalement baisser la garde face
à des géants du numérique qui serait
très content d'avoir un état qui
s'abstiendrait d'agir en la en la
matière et à partir du moment parce que
ça c'est un préalable à partir du moment
où la condition qui est celle qu'il n'y
ait pas d'arbitraire et levé alors des
personnes qui sont réticentes au départ
peuvent aussi évoluer je note d'ailleurs
que à l'assemblée nationale et peut-être
ici il y avait des personnes qui avaient
des doutes des interrogations et bus qui
ont cheminé aussi parce que les mini se
sont employés à convaincre et j'aimerais
essayer ici de convaincre les derniers
qu'ils soient réticents parce que dans
ce que j'ai entendu j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment une implication
serait à la fois inefficace et
dangereuse dire que il faut un peu
choisir ses arguments ça me fait penser
à cette fameuse fable du chaudron dans
l'interprétation des rêves de freud vous
savez le voisin après un chaudron et
puis les bréchet alors le voisin répond
un nom il est il était déjà ébréché il
me l'a jamais prêté et puis de toute
façon enfin il est il était il n'est pas
ébréché il ne l'a jamais prêté et il
était déjà est vrai chez avant même de
le prêter à dire que il faut choisir les
arguments qu'on utilise quand on veut
attaquer un système et à partir de là il
ne faut être ni par trop frileux ni par
trop fougueux sur ce sujet ce n'est
évidemment pas big brother qui est là du
tout proposé et je le dis à mes chers
collègues le principe de précaution ne
signifie pas un présupposé pour
l'inaction et donc par quelle serait
elle nous serait reproché de la même
façon que certains l'attaquent d'ores et
déjà donc je crois vraiment que l'
équilibre atteint sur le principe des
sur le principe fait à vis des libertés
publiques toutes les garanties qui ont
été mises et l'utilité démontré par des
avis qui sont extrêmement raisonnée
extrêmement précis montre que si on fait
finalement preuve utilisation de son
entendement de son raisonnement même
avec des préventions initial on peut
aboutir à
soutenir cette application que vous nous
proposez mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
merci beaucoup merci donc que monsieur
le ministre souhaite intervenir monsieur
cédric qu assez brièvement basque
d'avoir l'occasion de répondre aux
questions par la suite le président mais
certaines questions très précises ont
été posées donc je voulais y répondre
notamment sur une question importante
qui a été abordé par la présidente
assassiné par la sénatrice les
sénatrices laborde
c'est vrai que comme la cnil l'a
remarqué le droit d'accès et n'est pas
impossible mais pour une raison simple
c'est que nous n'avons pas accès et que
nous ne voulons pas faire en sorte de
pouvoir avoir accès et donc nous ne
pouvons pas dans le même mouvement
d'hier l'état ne doit rien avoir accès
ne pas être capable de faire un des
liens entre des contacts et des gens et
dire ah par contre si on nous le demande
et non pas capable de vous retrouver vos
contacts et donc c'est pour ça je
précise juste que la cnil au point 60
estiment après avoir dit que ce serait
préférable que le ministère peut écarter
l'application du droit d'accès je
rappelle tout de même que au sein de
l'application vous pouvez effacer vos
données sur le serveur mais en tout cas
vous ne pouvez pas demander un accès un
responsable de traitement sur la
question des des états européens et la
question du président retailleau je n'ai
pas je ne désespère pas de trouver une
voie commune que les nos partenaires
européens
comme vous le savez nous travaillons un
nouveau protocole qui s'appelle désirer
une première réunion s'est tenue avec
les italiens les espagnols les allemands
hier au sein de la commission européenne
si les choses avancent
il est possible que nous ayons quelque
chose je reste encore très prudents en
début du mois de juillet ce qui serait
effectivement une belle victoire pour la
construction européenne qui nécessitera
probablement d'autres discussions avec
eux les gars pas mais nous sommes pas
encore là s'agissant des questions de
jérôme durain et loïc hervé je veux vous
gardez de
avoir l'impression que nos versé dans
les solutions nice mme technologique
j'ai eu l'occasion ce matin en
commission des lois de dire que si vous
deviez avoir le choix entre les dégâts
d'une enquête sanitaire et stop comme il
je vous enjoignait de choisir les vegans
enquête sanitaire mais qu'il ne me
semblait pas qu'il faille en l'espèce
choisir et que ce que montrent les
études épidémiologiques c'est que
c'était complémentaires mais nécessaire
sur la question de centraliser
décentralisée sans rentrer vraiment trop
dans le détail
en fait vous avez le choix entre un
serveur central sous la responsabilité
de la direction générale de la santé ou
dans le cas de la solution décentraliser
une liste de contacts positifs sur un
serveur google
je vous laisse juge de du meilleur de la
meilleure des solutions et dernier
élément parce qu'il est intéressant que
vous avez cités ce qui s'est passé en
corée du sud effectivement avec cette
difficulté de dire que certains nouveaux
foyers avaient été découverts en fait au
sein de gens qui n'avaient pas du tout
envie qu'on sache qui j'étais en contact
mais je prendrai la documentation
inverse c'est à dire que ce que nous
voyons aujourd'hui dans l'expérience des
enquêteurs sanitaires c'est que oui ça
arrive y ait des français ils n'ont pas
le droit ils se réunissent à plus de dix
ils font des enterrements ils font des
mariages fondés match de foot parfois et
ben là c'est très difficile pour les
enquêteurs sanitaire parce que personne
n'a envie de dire avec qui il était et
au début on vous dit j'étais avec 10
personnes ce que vous allez voir sur dix
personnes donc pendant les premières 24
heures vous appeler dix personnes et
puis en tirant les films vous apercevez
qui n'étaient pas atteints et disent ils
et elles étaient 37 et 47 quand il se
passe un jour deux jours trois jours
quatre jours cinq jours ça arrive tous
les jours ça chez les enquêteurs
sanitaires et donc vous mettez une
semaine à recontacter des gens pendant
une semaine les gens pour une partie
d'entre eux sont asymptomatiques
et il continue à transmettre la maladie
et donc ce problème des gens qui sont
non coopératifs pour des raisons qu'on
ne doit pas dont on ne va pas débattre
ici il pousse au contraire à ce que nous
déployons stop évident parce que dans ce
cas la personne ne retrace et personne
ne va les chercher
je tenais à apporter ces quelques
précisions qui me semblait utile au
débat
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez été
con si nous allons procéder aux débats
sous la forme d'une série de onze
questions réponses dont les modalités
ont été fixés par la conférence des
présidents
trois pelles que chaque orateur dispose
de deux minutes maximum pour présenter
sa question avec une réponse du
gouvernement pour une durée équivalente
dans le cas où l'auteur la question
souhaite répliquer il dispose de 30
secondes supplémentaires à condition que
le temps initial de deux minutes n'est
pas été atteint la parole n'est pas
monsieur pierre ouzoulias merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président du
sénat même la ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la chronique de cette application c'est
l'histoire du renoncement de votre
gouvernement à notre souveraineté
numérique
je prendrai trois exemples rapide
d'abord je rappelle que la plateforme
des données de santé est hébergée par
microsoft
ensuite pour l'application que vous nous
proposez les données collectées par
cette application ne seront pas toutes
conservées par des saveurs installés en
france
c'est ce que nous dit la cnil isolé en
europe vous avez échoué à imposer vos
choix technologiques à apple et google
et vous subissez ce qu' ils vous impose
en conséquence c'est le point le plus
important pour être efficace
l'application devra être ouverte en
permanence pour recevoir des
informations du flux blue touche cette
perméabilité continue elle est
déconseillée par les constructeurs
c'est une car c'est une faille
importante de sécurité des terminaux
nous le savons tous ici l'utilisation de
cette application repose sur la
confiance
quelles garanties vous pouvez apporter
aux utilisateurs pour la sécurité des
données stockées sur les serveurs dont
je dis que certains n'étaient pas en
france
et surtout comment vous pouvez les
prémunir contre les risques de piratage
par une utilisation permanente du
bluetooth merci merci monsieur le
ministre
montrer monsieur le sénateur sur la
question des serveurs que vous avez
évoqué parce que je pense qu'elle fait
référence à un reproche qui nous a été
fait par la quadrature du net sur
l'utilisation du cap chat pardon nous
allons entrer dans un sujet un peu
compliqué le captcha ces sites où l'on
vous demande de reconnaissent des feux
rouges ou des voitures de telle manière
que vous puissiez on puisse vérifier que
vous êtes bien un être humain il
n'existe pas aussi bizarre que cela peut
paraître sur un portable de cap-chat
français et ce sera d'ailleurs un des
acquis collatéral mais principaux de
cette opération c'est que orange a
développé un cap chat pour portables
français ce cap chat c'est très
compliqué à développer nous ne leur ont
pas aujourd'hui nous ne leur ont pas
pour le 2 juin nous leurrons nous
l'aurons pour dans deux semaines nous
avons donc travaillé avec lenses suite à
l'avis de la cnil mais c'est quelque
chose auquel en fait nous travaillons
depuis un mois à faire en sorte pardon
du terme anglais mais je ne connais que
celui-ci d'encapsuler le cap chat dans
une web review pardon de encore une fois
du caractère ésotérique du sujet mais je
réponds techniquement de telle manière
qu'il n'y ait pas les fuites de données
qu'ils puissent être problématique donc
nous avons pris en charge ce sujet en
lien avec le site qui à dire vrai m'a
beaucoup soucier mais nous avons trouvé
une une solution sur les garanties
apportées en termes de sécurité
informatique
je lui dis nous prenons toutes les
mesures possibles
nous avons ouvert à des hackers éthiques
l'attak de nos serveurs ils vont trouver
des choses ils trouveront des choses il
trouve toujours des choses c'est la
meilleure manière d'avoir la meilleure
garantie possible nous prenons toutes
les garanties il n'existe pas je ne peux
jamais dire qu'il n'ya aucune faille
il y en a dans les plus importants
fichiers informatiques y compris des
agences de renseignement ce serait un
peu présomptueux de vous dire le
contraire
s'agissant du fichier stop qu'ovide
dernier élément l'application d'un pas
besoin d'être ouverte en permanence
effectivement le bluetooth fonctionne je
le dis en passage aujourd'hui la plupart
des français ont le blues
sous verre effectivement il ya des
risques d' attaque mais il ne semble pas
que les personnes dans cette salle qui
ait jamais eue le bluetooth ouvert se
soit jamais fait attaquer et donc là
encore il s'agit d'une question de
proportionnalité si c'est utile c'est la
volée cela en vaut la peine
merci monsieur pierre ouzou lien vous
avez 50 et une seconde de répliques
monsieur le ministre
la confiance elle n'y est pas et si on
répondait à la demande de notre collègue
et moi jeune installerait par
l'application vous m'avez absolument pas
convaincu parce que je vous ai posé une
question très précise vous mais vous
m'avez répondu avec les captchas ne
s'était pas du tout ça je vous ai
demandé si toutes les données manipulées
par par l'application serait sur des
serveurs français n'a pas répondu je
n'ai pas confiance
merci les paroles et maintenant monsieur
dany wattebled y dorment madame anne
denis ce monsieur ministre chers
collègues concernant l'application de
traçage des cas contactez la france a
fait le choix d'une architecture
centralisée les informations issues
téléphone remonteront un serveur qui
sera chargé de les traiter afin de
notifier aux personnes concernées
qu'elles ont été en contact avec une
personne qui sienne est malade de façon
anonyme
cette solution également choisi par le
royaume uni a cependant fait l'objet
d'une opposition de la part de google et
d'apple
ces derniers qu'ils détiennent ensemble
monopole des systèmes d'exploitation des
smartphones ont fait pression pour que
les habitants au traçage utah lui
utilise une utilisation centralisée
c'est à dire que ces informations
restent sur les téléphones et ne soit
pas stockées sur un serveur central
l'allemagne 6 vient seul entamant par la
suisse l'italie a accepté de recourir la
solution préconisée par les géants du
numérique
tous les pays européens n'ont pas la
même structure d'application au premier
rang desquels la france et l'allemagne
cette division au sein du couple franco
allemand nous interpelle car ces
applications vocation est utilisé à
travers l'europe dès que les frontières
seront rouvertes au sein de l'espace
schengen monsieur le ministre
ma question est double
et portent ces différences
d'architecturé ne seront elles pas un
obstacle à l'inter opérabilité des
différentes applications nationales
par ailleurs monsieur nice pour il nous
dira également qu'elle soit différence
en matière de cybersécurité
y at il une architecture plus
vulnérables que l'autre je remercie
merci monsieur le ministre oui monsieur
le sénateur d'abord je partage votre
regret il est vrai que les chemins
européens ont divergé sur la question et
que pour des raisons politiques
pas pour des raisons techniques mais
pour maison politique l'allemagne a
choisi et a affirmé préférer est passé
par la solution développée par apple et
google plutôt que par la solution
française
je ne vais pas vous mentir la
possibilité que les solutions
décentralisée et centralisé comme vous
les avez cités soit interopérable est
très limité il sera très compliqué
d'avoir une solution interopérable au
niveau de l'europe
je le regrette je le regrette surtout
facialement d'ailleurs parce que en
termes de déplacements vous conviendrez
avec moi que les frontaliers
téléchargement deux applications ils
survivront comme cela si vous souhaitez
aller en vacances en espagne vous
téléchargerez l'application espagnol
vous serez couvert
c'est juste facialement je trouve que
pour l'europe de la souveraineté
numérique
il est dommage que ce choix était fait
par un certain nombre de nos partenaires
dont je ne pense d'ailleurs que
l'histoire n'est pas totalement terminée
j'ai signé avec mes collègues allemand
espagnol italien et portugais une
tribune hier sur la souveraineté
numérique européenne particulièrement
agressive peut-être en tout cas brigante
à l'égard d'apple et google et donc nous
travaillons quand même à ce deuxième où
cette troisième voie que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure avec le président le président
retailleau pour avoir ces solutions
interopérables et nous ferons tout pour
faire en sorte d'avoir une solution
européenne
s'agissant de l'intérêt comparer des
deux solutions à titre personnel je n'ai
pas de religion ce que me dit l'ansi ce
que me dit l'inria ce que dit un papier
signé par des chercheurs opposés aux
trasim et donc qui ne sont pas parties
prenantes c'est que la solution
décentralisée est significativement plus
facile à attaquer que la solution
centralisée
encore faut-il
faire confiance dans un état
démocratique à l'état sur le fait qu'ils
utilisent bien las de serveur central
pour ce à quoi il va servir et pas autre
chose
merci monsieur le ministre
donc la parole à madame catherine morin
desailly mes chers collègues ça fait
près d'une heure que nous discutons
l'application au stop qu'ovide bourreau
compte quel sera son niveau d'efficacité
et elles au point techniquement
est ce que finalement être efficace
qu'elle sera pas interopérable avec les
systèmes des pays voisins
est ce qu'il n'ya pas les trous de
sécurité d'ailleurs je renvoie à
l'excellente audition que nous avons eu
ce matin la commission de la culture
avec des chercheurs du cnrs et de
l'inria bois pour moi en réalité la
question est ailleurs
la question essentielle pour moi elle
réside dans la centralisation des
données sur la plate forme adobe
merci entre parenthèses pour la
francophonie donc cette plateforme créée
par le ministère de de la santé qui
faisait l'objet de l'article 6 que nous
avons largement débattue il ya quelques
jours et qui rassemblera les données de
santé recueillies par les brigades alors
cette pas a priori par sopko vite
quoique peut imaginer à terme certaines
interconnexion le vrai paradoxe monsieur
le ministre c'est que vous revendiquez à
juste titre vouloir faire de la
souveraineté un enjeu est dans le
dossier ce top cow vide
vous mettez en avant le fait que nous
renonçons à la solution prônée par les
suisses et les allemands parce que c'est
google et apple
dont acte mais le choix de gestion de
cette plate forme ebs date arabe
il est bien confié un gars femmes
charbonneau retailleau il est bien
confine à microsoft je sais vous étiez
conseiller à l'elysée à l'époque et vous
avez pesé dans le choix de confier la
gestion à microsoft
là est le vrai sujet c'est un choix
lourd de conséquences parce que
l'application stop vide ça sera une
péripétie dans l'histoire des
innovations numériques tandis que
l'appliquent la plateforme elle va durer
elle est faite pour durer
il y aura des choix assez irréversible
dans le traitement nous aurons à terme
de nos données de santé alors je vous
pose la question pourquoi n'at-on pas
choisi
une société une entreprise française
internationale de dimension européenne
je crois que il y en avait il y avait
des solutions
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente je vais être extrêmement
direct avec vous effectivement j'étais
conseiller à l'elysée à l'époque je n'ai
pas pesé dans le choix mais j'ai vu les
déterminants qui ont présidé la seule la
réponse aller simple nous avions choix
entre prendre une solution française et
l'évaluation technique et est très
claire qui ne nous permettaient pas et
je le regrette qui ne nous permettaient
pas de faire les recherches
scientifiques que nous souhaitions faire
sur les données de santé et quand je dis
les recherches scientifiques c'est ce
que nous avons fait pendant la crise
l'udc au vide les recherches de
comorbidité les recherches
d'interactions médicamenteuses
les solutions françaises étant donné le
retard européen dans le cloud que je
regrette profondément mais je rappelle
juste que les investissements d'amazones
parents ces 22 milliards de dollars 22
milliards de dollars pour une seule
entreprise
étant donné les retards européen dans le
cloud nous n'avions pas la possibilité
de faire tourner des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle aussi
développé sur infrastructures françaises
que sur infrastructure américaine taylor
il y avait un choix cornélien qui était
savoir est-ce qu'on mettait en avant
d'abord l'efficacité sanitaire avec un
certain nombre de garanties et je vous
le dis je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de
fuite de données mais j'aurais préféré
avoir un industriel européen ne serait
ce que pour tirer l'industrie européenne
mettons d'abord l'efficacité sanitaire
où la question de la souveraineté avec
une moindre efficacité sanitaire
cette question nous a occupé longtemps
très longtemps à la fin
après avoir discuté avec un certain
nombre de scientifiques après avoir
discuté avec un certain nombre de
chercheurs en intelligence artificielle
pour comprendre jusqu'au bout ce qu'on
pouvait faire ce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire nous avons choisi de
contractualiser avec la société
microsoft qui était la mieux-disante en
termes de technologie avec un certain
nombre de garanties techniques et bien
évidemment juridique sur laquelle je ne
reviens pas je pense que la seule leçon
qu'il faut tirer de cela c'est que dans
l'après crise la question du cloud pour
toutes les entreprises
et pour les institutions françaises est
absolument extrêmement urgente merci
madame morin desailly vous avez 33
secondes par croire qu'ils avaient pas
de solutions françaises européennes et
internationales aux verts j'aurais très
bien pu corrida tc le cahier des charges
avait été aussi fait en fonction des
acteurs européens dont nous disposons
parce que dans ce domaine tout est en
train d'être construit et microsoft fait
de même d'ailleurs son pdg goldman sachs
a bien étudié la question s'il marche
européenne l'intéressant c'est qui sait
bien que derrière il y aura des
développements dans le cadre de
l'économie de la santé où les données
sont si importantes et si convoité
seulement il n'y a pas une marche est
réellement passé puisque ça a été une
extension d'un marché préalable
d'après ce que j'ai bien compris et
qu'on n'a pas repassé un marché nouveau
pour confier la gestion de cette
plateforme on vient j'aurais très bien
pu candidate et voilà et je regrette qu'
une absence de patriotisme français
européens à cet égard pourquoi on met
pas le paquet dans nos politiques
industrielles pour mettre justement les
moyens du développement alors que tout
est en train de se construire que s'y
recoller tout est en train de se
construire pour avoir nos solutions et
encre et c'est bien ce que voulait
cédric villani ce qui préconisait aussi
dans le cadre de l'intelligence
artificielle en créant en europe un
écosystème qui nous est propre
pourquoi c'est un choix non pas
technique monsieur le ministre que vous
avez fait un choix politique beaucoup
débordé merci de conclure la parole est
à monsieur philippe bas monsieur le
président ainsi monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
nous avons vous le savez beaucoup
travaillé sur cette application qui
était en devenir
nous l'avons vu progressivement atterrir
nous avons auditionné plusieurs fois
nous avons auditionné le président du
comité scientifique nous avons
auditionné la présidente de la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés
nos deux rapporteurs spéciaux loïc hervé
dany wattebled se sont beaucoup investis
sur le dossier
l'impression que j'en retire c'est que
progressivement les garanties se sont
accumulés et les ambitions ont été
revues à la baisse
sans doute quand on rentre dans
l'atmosphère et consorts du domaine des
idées générales et en apesanteur pour
arriver à définir l'architecturé d'un
dispositif en arrive-t-on à ce genre de
conclusion les garanties sont
sérieusement amélioré transparence
volontariat sécurité des données
autorité indépendante
et puis souveraineté puisque nous
n'avons pas transiger avec la volonté
d'un système français ne dépendant pas
des gars fin mais en même temps nous
avons un dispositif dans les ambitions
sont revues à la baisse beaucoup de
choses alerte demain beaucoup d' alerte
qui ne seront pas donnés alors qu'on
aura rencontré des personnes contaminées
et un système qui est fini par
ressembler étrangement dans ses
potentialités à ce qu'on a vu à
singapour alors je me dis qu'il faut
laisser sa chance ce dispositif mais je
me dis en même temps que pour que le jeu
en vaille vraiment la chandelle il
faudrait quand même qu'on est sur la
table aussi la dimension financière quel
est le coût monsieur le ministre de ce
dispositif
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
le président est monsieur le président
bah j'ai peur de ne pas pouvoir être
beaucoup plus précis que je l'étais ce
matin en commission des lois pour vous
dire donc que jusqu'ici
l'application n'a rien coûté mise à part
sur le budget général de l'état
les salaires des chercheurs et des
fonctionnaires qui ont travaillé
quelques dizaines l'ensemble des
entreprises françaises que j'ai eu
l'occasion de citer beaucoup d'autres au
total plus de 100 personnes qui ont
travaillé sur le sujet l'ont fait de
manière gracieuse
je veux ici en profiter pour les en
remercier
elles n'ont pas non plus de propriété
intellectuelle sur ce sujet c'est
important de le souligner à partir
d'aujourd'hui à partir la semaine
prochaine nous entrerons dans une autre
phase puisque là ne seront plus dans une
partie de développement mais quelque
part nous entrerons en fonctionnement
normal et donc nous avons commencé je ne
suis pas capable de répondre aujourd'hui
parce que nous n'avons pas terminé les
négociations et les discussions avec ces
entreprises mais je veux rassurer sur le
montant global que cela représente
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire ces
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
maximum par mois donc c'est extrêmement
limité et je disais je crois que c'était
aux sénateurs hervé ce matin que
j'aurais pu éluder la question disant
que la santé n'a pas de prix mais quoi
qu'il en coûte
comme vous le dites mais si on fait on
pousse l'intérêt pour la question jusqu
à évaluer le rapport coût efficacité
compte tenu de ce que représentent les
lits de réanimation
évitez par l'application il me semble
que ce rapport coût efficacité est
largement positif merci la parole est
maintenant madame corinne ferrer
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues pour
lutter contre l'épidémie de covile 19 le
gouvernement a décidé de mettre en place
un système de traçage des contacts des
malades à l'aide d'une application
mobile et de par sa nature forcément
intrusif dans la vie privée je regrette
que l'urgence que nous ressentons tous
collectivement face à la crise sanitaire
actuelle fasse oublier que le numérique
doit être au service de chaque citoyen
qu'il ne doit porter atteinte ni à
l'identité humaine ni aux droits de
l'homme ni à la vie privée ni aux
libertés individuelles au public dans le
contexte il est légitime de s'interroger
sur l'opportunité de lancer l'opéra
plication stop que vides alors même que
nous connaissons un début de baisse
épidémie qu est que nous ne partipera
tic ont toujours pas une politique
massive de test sans compter que les
français les plus impactés les plus
fragiles en espèces les plus âgés sont
aussi les moins sensibilisés aux
nouvelles technologies et aux
applications téléchargeables sur
téléphone portable
de plus bien que 77% des français
possèdent un smartphone il faudrait que
plus de 80% de la population utilise
l'application pour que cela soit
efficace
vous reconnaissez vous même monsieur le
ministre qu'il ya une incertitude
technologique
dans ces conditions il serait donc
préférable d'admettre que stop qu'ovide
présente un intérêt limité dans la lutte
contre le coc vide 19 et surtout qu'elle
porte une atteinte manifestement
disproportionnée aux droits et libertés
des citoyens
je veux aussi insister sur la situation
particulière des mineurs des mineurs
équipés de smartphones qui pourront
demain téléchargez l'application comme
le rappelle la cnil dans son avis rendu
hier
il conviendra de veiller au contenu de
l'information diffusée et de s'assurer
que ce top cow vide soit utilisé à bon
escient que huit anges d'alert
susceptibles d'être adressée aux as et
adolescents soient adaptés et bien
interprété
alors ma question est donc la suivante
monsieur ministre avez vous prévu que
soit intégrée dans l'information fournie
aux utilisateurs de développements
spécifiques à la fois pour les mineurs
adolescents mais aussi pour leurs
parents merci monsieur le ministre
oui oui
la sénatrice vous dire très rapidement
qu'effectivement la clinique nous a
demandé d'intégrer même si juridiquement
la base légale ne nous y oblige pas une
information aux mineurs et que donc
lorsque vous allez initialiser
l'application vous avez une partie sur
les conditions générales d'utilisation
qui est assez simple mais que danser
dans ces éléments là nous allons
intégrer des éléments d'informations
disant que s'il est mineur si des
personnes est mineure elle doit le faire
avec l'autorisation de ses parents
nous ne pouvons pas aller plus loin que
l'information pour une raison simple
c'est que comme nous ne demandons aucune
information nous ne pouvons pas faire en
sorte que de vérifier l'âge de la
personne et donc la cnil avec laquelle
nous avons discuté a jugé cette approche
équilibrée et nous a seulement demandé
d'informer ce que nous ferons je profite
également de cette réponse pour rebondir
sur les questions de la fracture
numérique que vous évoquez parce que je
pense qu'elles sont très importantes
pour dire d'abord que ce n'est pas parce
que effectivement certaines populations
plus de 70 ans seulement 40 % de
possession de smartphones n'ont pas
accès à l'application à ce jour qu'elles
ne sont pas protégés les brigades
sanitaire vous protège sans préjudice de
savoir si vous avez une application ou
pas c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est vrai que la
population visons prioritairement ses
les urbains actifs qui prennent les
transports en commun qui vont dans les
bars et les restaurants
parce que c'est cette population là qui
fait circuler le virus le virus est très
dangereux pour les personnes âgées mais
ce ne sont pas selon les travaux
épidémiologique puis on le peut le
comprendre comme ça des personnes âgées
qui font circuler le virus ce qui vont
circuler virus ce sont des urbains
ceux qui prennent les transports en
commun encore une fois qu'ils auront
demain dans des restaurants ou qui vont
dans les supermarchés quand il ya
beaucoup de monde et donc c'est cette
population là que nous cherchons à
couvrir prioritaires mais nous tenons à
faire en sorte de pouvoir protéger toute
la population c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que nous travaillons
à horizon de cet été je l'espère pour
essayer d'avoir un objet connecté qui
permettent
deux d'être distribué d'être acquis par
nos concitoyens qui n'ont pas de
smartphone pour couvrir aussi cette
population afin qu'elle ne se retrouve
pas sans solution merci la parole est
maintenant monsieur jean claude requier
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues au détour de la dramatique
crise sanitaire du coc u19 le numérique
est un grand pas dans le monde de la
santé en particulier le projet d'une
application de traçage des personnes
touchées par le virus a suscité de
nombreuses réflexions et discussions
publiques
le gouvernement a finalement décidé de
lancer l'outil stop qu'ovide dans nos
parents ce soir pour compléter sa
politique de lutte contre la propagation
de l'épidémie
je ne reviendrai pas sur la question de
la protection des données
si ce n'est pour appeler que mon groupe
comme l'a dit ce fatras d'avoir tout à
l'heure et bien entendu attachée au
respect des libertés individuelles et
qui prend à l'acte dernières
recommandations
la cnil en particulier sur les
précautions renforcée autour du volet
concernant les destinataires et
d'accéder aux données de l'application
dans le cas de ce débat il ferait vous
posez sur le ministre au nom de yvon
collin une question sur le plan
technique
la france a choisi le protocole robert
apple et google développe également
leurs propres applications qu'elles
jugent plus respectueux de la vie privée
par rapport aux applications existantes
je ne jugerai pas le choix
d'applications robert parce que c'est ce
qui est des initiatives européennes
paneuropéenne puis à 6 8 6 nicky et
racing excusez moi je parle anglais avec
un peu l'accent du tournoi des six
nations
c'est donc une bonne chose d'autant plus
que l'on peut comprendre et même
partager l'enjeu de souveraineté qui se
joue derrière l'outil de traçage
mais apple permettra ne permettant pas
l'accès au bout tout en continu à
l'arrière-plan d'une application stop
kobe tu ne pourrais pas semble-t-il est
utilisé sur l'iphone peu de téléphones
pourrait donc installé stop coït
or nous savons que l'efficacité d'une
application de traçage repose sur son
adaptation par nombre critique de nos
concitoyens idéalement au moins 20% dans
ces conditions quel est votre sim
d'utilisateurs par ailleurs quel impact
aura l'application
si elle reste ouverte à l'arrière-plan
la batterie du téléphone
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le président inquiet
la question que vous posez été au coeur
des tests que nous avons fait ces deux
dernières semaines pour le rappeler nous
avons testé les 100 portables les plus
utilisés par les français de dix sept
marques différentes
effectivement une des complexités à
laquelle nous nous heurtions était de
faire en sorte que l'application
lorsqu'elle était en arrière-plan sur
l'iphone ne soit pas éteinte
automatiquement par les iphone ce qui
était un des problèmes que nous
rencontrions la solution technique que
nous avons trouvé qui est la même que
celle que les anglais utilisent et le
fait que quand vous aurez un iphone dans
la poche et qu'il s'étendra
graduellement dès que vous croiserez
quelqu'un qui a un téléphone sous
android pour rappeler la part de marché
d iphone c'est un peu moins de 20% la
part de marché d'android c'est un peu
plus de 80% et donc vous croisez dans la
rue très régulièrement des gens qui ont
un androïde l'android réveil l'iphone
c'est un moyen détourné un peu
insatisfaisant qui ne marche pas à tous
les coups mais ce que les tests ont pu
montrer ces derniers jours c'était
d'abord que ce moyen là n'avait pas
d'effet dirimant sur la batterie il ya
effectivement une petite hausse de la
consommation mais sans que ce soit sans
que la vie de votre batterie de
téléphone de l'ordre de quelques
pourcents et deuxième chose que c'est ce
ce mécanisme de contournement marché
bien de manière très satisfaisante pour
vous donner une idée globale
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure de
dire que nous captons entre 75 et 80%
des gens que nous devons capter c'est
encore insatisfaisant nous allons
continuer à améliorer le protocole nous
faisons d'ailleurs au niveau européen
sur cette question du bluetooth avec les
allemands les anglais et certains
acteurs américains qui semble-t-il ne
sont pas forcément si avancée que ça sur
le sujet en tout cas pas forcément plus
que les français mais nous avons
considéré que voilà entre 75 et 80% de
personnes que ce soit dans le métro à
l'air libre dans un supermarché
c'était suffisamment solides pour que
d'ailleurs nous en tirions une
conséquence qui est importante quand
vous serez notifié
vous pourrez prendre contact avec votre
médecin et avoir accès à un test et un
arrêt de travail
c'est bien que si nous acceptons d'avoir
cette conséquence forte
nous avons confiance dans la solidité et
la fiabilité du système informatique
merci les paroles et maintenant à
monsieur martin lévriers merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président du
sénat madame et monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous ai voulu vous
avez voulu faire de ce top cow vie d'un
projet français piloté par l'inria et
avec l'appui de nombreux industriels qui
s'investit dans notre pays
vous avez fait le choix de recourir à
notre savoir faire national pour le
mettre au service de l'intérêt général
et du progrès humain dans la domaine où
on excelle souvent trop discrètement
vous avez tout à leur parler de panache
ma moustache en a freiné à ce jour les
tests ont été menés sur les 100
références de téléphones les plus
utilisés par les français de dix sept
marques différentes
les tests ont démontré que l'application
fonctionner de manière très
satisfaisante sur l'ensemble des modèles
du parc de référence pour autant près de
23% des français ne disposent pas de
smartphone ou ne sont pas à l'aise avec
le numérique
or le virus n'a pas de frontières et
touche toutes les classes sociales
ce public outre le fait qu'il n'est pas
imaginable qu'ils puissent être exclus
du processus
désir souvent être acteur dans ce combat
contre le commis de 19
c'est pourquoi de nombreuses entreprises
françaises se sont investis dans la
recherche et le développement de
produits innovants pouvant répondre à
cette attente
je pourrais citer par exemple sigfox une
société toulousaine spécialiste des
réseaux télécoms bas débit qui
travaillent un prototype de brasse les
connecter indépendant de google et
d'apple
la france comme d'autres pays d'ailleurs
ne ferme pas la porte à la solution du
bracelet connecter pour des tiers
dépourvu de smartphones à l'instar des
personnes âgées bien sûr où des
personnes modestes
le gouvernement doit pouvoir proposer
des solutions à ces publics pour qu'ils
puissent eux aussi sur la base du
volontariat compléter l'action des
médecins et de l'assurance maladie
monsieur le ministre à ce jour l'option
d'un bracelet connectée est elle
toujours envisager d'autres alternatives
de ce type sont elles à l'étude pour
favoriser la participation bénévole de
ces français éloigné des objets
connectés et si oui
l'état entend t-il contribuer à la
distribution de ces outils je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre oui monsieur
le président monsieur le sénateur
léveillé et je crois avoir commencé à
répondre tout à l'heure à cette question
je veux ajouter quelques éléments
d'abord que nous avons fait travailler
sur cette application depuis plusieurs
semaines des spécialistes de l'inclusion
numérique et de l'accessibilité aux
personnes en situation de handicap et
que donc l'application sera simple j'ai
peur qu'elle soit un peu décevante pour
ceux d'entre vous qui accepteraient de
la télécharger dans la mesure où elle
est très simple mais elle est du coup
très compréhensible y aller par par
ailleurs accessibles aux personnes en
situation de handicap ce qui me semble
extrêmement important
deuxième élément nous allons tout faire
au delà des éléments que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure pour pousser l'adoption de
cette application auprès des populations
que nous avons plus de mal à contacter
je pense par exemple aux associations de
collectivités territoriales avec lequel
nous souhaitons travailler certaines
nous ont donné leur accord même commencé
à travailler avec nous je pense aussi
aux associations caritatives que je
verrai enfin que je verrai par visio
demain parce que nous tenons à faire en
sorte de protéger également c'est ces
populations s'agissant de l'objet
connectés que vous évoquez juste donné
un peu plus d'éléments c'est un objet
connecté qui est développé par la
société withings est une société
française et nous travaillons
aujourd'hui sur la solution d'une montre
la montre offrant par ailleurs l'intérêt
de ne pas pouvoir être perdu dans
diverses situations y compris chez des
personnes âgées et les premiers tests
sont bons tiens des premiers résultats
montrent que nous réussissons à
incorporer le protocole robert au sein
de la montre reste un certain nombre de
questions de déploiement
d'industrialisation massive si jamais
nous devons le faire qu'ils sont encore
largement devant nous pour vous le dire
mais voilà nous avons tenu à travailler
un objet connecté qui puisse permettre
là aussi de toucher les personnes qui
sont plus éloignés du numérique il
faudra aussi qu'on essaie discussions
avec les colis territoriale vous savoir
dès lors que nous avions cet objet ça
coûte quand même après
50 euros par objet quels efforts nous
faisons pour protéger les françaises
tout ça est encore devant nous mais ce
sera l'objet j'imagine de débats
extrêmement important merci la parole
est maintenant monsieur olivier nous
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat 20 à mme la ministre
monsieur le ministre chers collègues je
tiens d'abord à remercier toutes celles
et ceux qui ont travaillé sur ce sujet
les rapporteurs les orateurs qui nous
ont parfaitement expliquer les enjeux du
débat mme après avoir écouté les uns les
autres personnellement ce n'est pas tant
le danger de l'application au stop
qu'ovide qui m'inquiète le plus mais son
efficacité
il faut prendre cette application à sa
juste proportion
il serait paradoxal à mon sens d'être
plus exigeants en termes de données
personnelles avec stop qu'ovide qui avec
les gars fort bien sûr j'entends les
réactions des uns et des autres nous
sommes peut-être même ici plus au coeur
d'un débat sur l' équilibre à trouver
entre les protections collectives et les
libertés publiques que dans un débat sur
la lutte contre le coc vide 19 mai mes
chers collègues même si certains
indicateurs peuvent sembler rassurant la
maladie rôde toujours
elles menacent encore les plus fragiles
ceux d'entre nous qui risquent leur vie
et rappelons que nous ne disposons pour
l'heure ni d'un vaccin ni d'un
traitement et nous n'avons pas
l'assurance que nous en aurons très
prochainement alors faudrait-il le
rester passifs et compter sur le seul
confinement avec son cortège de drames
économiques et sociaux pour lutter
contre la maladie ou son éventuel retour
je m'étais exprimé en ce sens lors du
débat sur les brigades anti qu'ovide je
persiste et signe nous n'avons pas
d'autre moyen de lutter contre la
maladie s'était dit que de tester tracé
est isolé alors si l'application stop
kovy participent y participe tant mieux
soyons clairs le problème ce n'est pas
le recours à la technologie qui est paré
qui par essence est liberticide c'est
l'usagé qu'on leur en fait ce n'est pas
l'épée qui tue c'est le bras
ce sera notre rôle de parlementaire
d'être vigilant sur ce point
en attendant notre devoir est de tout
faire pour protéger les populations et
relancer l'activité de notre pays alors
monsieur le
ministre ma question est double la
première vous avez fixé une ambition 56%
60% pour l'usager quels moyens allez
vous consacrer pour promouvoir cette
application est l'autre question c'est
est ce que d'autres pays sont
susceptibles de faire le même choix que
nous le choix que de la souveraineté
numérique notamment en europe je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur j'ai peur de vous décevoir je
n'espère pas que nous aurons 56% de la
population couverte
je n'y crois pas pour tout dire je crois
qu'il ya je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de
vérifier je crois qu'il ya une seule
application qui est possédé par plus de
60% de la population française
une seule est donc mon objectif n'est
certainement pas d'en mettre en avoir 60
% et d'ailleurs 60% de la population
française n'aurait pas beaucoup de sens
puisque nous réfléchissons en terme de
bassin de vie donc si une vie découverte
c'est une très bonne chose et c'est là
que nous ciblons principalement les
perdre et urbain active n'y revient pas
mais qui sont ceux qui ont le plus de
smartphones ce que montrent les travaux
épidémiologique encore une fois et la
dernière livraison a eu lieu hier de la
part d'oxford et de l'impérial college
c'est que dès les premiers
téléchargements cela évite des
contaminations et que on peut estimer
d'après mes discussions les discussions
que j'ai eues avec christophe fraser le
patron de ces recherches qui à partir
d'un peu moins de 10% d'un bassin de vie
on a un effet systémique de protection
etc ensuite l'efficacité augmente de
manière linéaire mais vraiment il
l'écrit lui-même dès les premiers
téléchargements cela évite des
contaminations sur la question de la
souveraineté nous avons jojo à ce jour
les anglais qui sont alignés avec nous
s'agissant des italiens et des allemands
des autrichiens et suisses ont fait un
autre choix aux espagnols
réservent encore leur avis je crois que
vraiment ce qui doit mobiliser notre
énergie c'est la recherche d'un
compromis ce protocole désiré qui peut
être à la fois déployé en centralisés et
décentralisés qui pose encore des
questions techniques compte tenu de sa
complexité mais qui est encore plus
protecteur de la vie privée alors
j'espère que nous allons tirer le fil de
faire en sorte que nous trouvions un
chemin européen il reste encore à ce
jour
malheureusement un certain merci dieu la
parole est maintenant à madame angèle
près bil'in à pardon monsieur milon chez
monsieur le président mes excuses
monsieur alain milon le président du
sénat madame et messieurs ministre mes
chers collègues pendant plusieurs
semaines donc la vie de notre pays s'est
pratiquement arrêté pendant plusieurs
semaines les français ont été enfermés
chez eux privés de liberté fondamentale
d'aller et de venir pendant plusieurs
semaines notre pays à lutter à l'aveuglé
contre l'épidémie de kovy 19 il y à un
mois
le triptyque protéger tester isolé a
guidé les conditions de notre liberté
pour partie retrouvée il consiste à
passer de la lutte à la veuve à la lutte
informé notre statégie a été largement
guidés par les capacités disponibles en
équipements de protection en test en
application aucune de ses capacités ne
suffit à elle seule mais toutes sont je
crois nécessaire et vu des connaissances
que nous avons actuellement sur virus
peut être pas encore suffisantes
d'autres pays ont procédé autrement je
pense à la corée du sud qui instruite
par des épidémies précédentes a misé sur
la connaissance la plus fine possible de
la propagation du virus et sur
l'information de la population
si nous n'avons pas été prêt monsieur le
ministre pour cette épidémie
il n'est pas interdit de ne pas l'être
pour la prochaine
l'application stop&go vide en test
grandeur grandeur nature pourrait servir
à nouveau face à une maladie encore plus
insidieuse et à la létalité encore plus
élevé si nous n'avons pas été prêt pour
cette épidémie d'autres le seront au
moins de garantie pour nos données de
santé nos libertés notre souveraineté
comme l'ont dit et philippe bas et bruno
retailleau pour informer plutôt que d'en
fermer
je suis monsieur le ministre favorable à
l' usage d'une application résonnait
maîtrisé avec des garanties publiques et
individuelles
je m'interroge cependant sur un point
qui ne s'est pas le même point que celui
d'olivier henno
quels sont les fondements d évaluation à
10 50 ou 60% de diffusion de
l'application au sein de la population
comme conclusion de son efficacité
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mais non il y à une étude
principal qui travaillent sur ce sujet
là c'est l'étude dans le premier opus
est paru le 13 mars dernier de l'équipe
que je citais tout à l'heure d'oxford et
de l'impérial college qui a travaillé
sur cette problématique du contact
racing pardon de l'anglicisme de la part
de gens qui en fait sont des
spécialistes des mollahs du srpt ars du
maire ce et qui donc quand il le raconte
dès cette époque là avait imaginé le
déploiement de ces outils numériques
parce que vraiment le principal problème
de la propagation de cette épidémie mais
vous le savez c'est que ce sont des gens
qui ne sont pas conscients d'avoir le
virus qui propage l'épidémie et donc il
continue soit qu'il soit en période
d'incubation soit qu'ils soient
asymptomatiques de manière définitive
et c'est cette étude mais qui par
ailleurs et a le soutien de l'inserm
l'institut pasteur et confirme les
travaux qui sont menés
sylla qui est vraiment centrale elle
devrait d'ailleurs être précisées dans
les jours qui viennent pour la petite
histoire elle devait des précisions
devait sortir les semaines précédentes
mais certains c'était chercheurs ont été
malades dont elle a été décalée c'est
cette étude qui est la plus complète ne
serait ce que parce que la prochaine
livraison intégrera des éléments de
dynamique comportementale etc etc qui
permettent encore mieux de mobiles et de
modéliser et qui me permettent de vous
donner le chiffre par exemple des 10%
qui vient des discussions que j'ai eues
avec eux avec cette équipe là c'est
vraiment ce corpus cette équipe qui on
le met la meilleure connaissance quand
vous en discutez avec les
épidémiologistes comme simon cauchemez
arnaud fontanet de pasteur ou victoria
que lisa de l'inserm il trouve qu'il
considère comme extrêmement solide et il
considère d'ailleurs c'est ce qui les a
amenés à prendre position officiellement
pour les outils de protection des
contacts c'est très intéressant si vous
voulez je tiens à votre disposition de
regarder l'impact en termes de morts et
en termes de contamination d'un jour
gagner dans la prévenance des contacts
c'est c'est exponentiel
c'est exponentiel ça se fait au bout ça
ne s'adonne au bout de quelques d'une
dizaine de jours des différences en
dizaines de millions de morts ce qui
évidemment cette caractéristique de ces
courbe exponentielle
mais je serais ravi d'en parler en
dehors et au moins un peu plus de dix
minutes de minutes avec vous en dehors
de cet hémicycle
merci donc maintenant la parole et bien
madame angèle préville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat madame et monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues limiter la
propagation de l'épidémie en cassant les
chaînes de transmission est un impératif
que nous partageons recourir à une
application de suivi des contacts
rapprochés est un choix très discutable
tout d'abord s'agissant de son
efficacité
la théorie pure et parfaite sur laquelle
se basent application est sans même
prendre en compte la question du
volontariat difficilement transposable à
la réalité des français c'est nier
l'exclusion numérique qu'elles soient
basées sur la couverture inégale de
notre territoire sur l'équipement en
smartphones de la population loin d'être
à 100% sur ce sujet plus de 20 % des
français sont d'office exclus et en
majorité populations à risque vous vous
apprêtez à mettre en place un système
qui davance est très difficilement
opérationnel d'autre part la génération
de données de santé en transit dans le
cloud comporte un risque important de
vol de ces données
ce sont la vie privée des utilisateurs
leurs données personnelles et de santé
qui sont en jeu le piratage n'est pas
une vue d'esprit et à n'en pas douter
toutes ces données suscite d'ores et
déjà des convoitises que vous semblez
ignorer tout ce qui est sur nos
smartphones n'est ni anonyme ni secret
aussi ma question porte sur le risque
qui pèse sur la sécurité informatique
d'une telle application pouvez vous
garantir que ce site système ne sera pas
à quai merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président
dams et messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice je vais très directement je
ne peux pas vous le garantir mais je
peux vous garantir une chose c'est que
nous prenons toutes les mesures parfois
disproportionnées par rapport à la
sensibilité des données qui sont
contenus pourquoi je dis ça parce que si
j'étais à coeur je préférais
probablement si je suis intéressé par
les données personnelles des français
m'attaquer aux systèmes informatiques de
certains hôpitaux avec des noms des
prénoms des historiques de pathologie ce
qu'ils font d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais
le niveau de protection
le niveau de protection dont
bénéficieront les données de ce top
covin je rappelle que les données de ce
top rues vides ce ne sont qu'une liste
de crypto identifiant qui sont des
contacts de personnes testées positives
il n'existe nulle part nulle part de
liste de personnes testées positives ces
données là sont d'un intérêt extrêmement
limité vraiment très compliqué à
identifier et donc tout est faux
d'affaires de proportionnalité nous
n'avons pris toutes les mesures que nous
pouvions en termes de protection des
données
ces données se sont par ailleurs d'une
dangerosité entre guillemets limité nous
avons jeu le site est encore aujourd'hui
demander à des hackers d'attaquer cette
notre solution de telle manière à ce
qu'ils puissent découvrir des failles
que nous puissions les combler mais ce
que je pense que cela doit évoquer pour
nous c'est que je regrette encore
aujourd'hui que le niveau de préparation
des hôpitaux des entreprises des
institutions ne sommes pas mieux lotis
que les autres en termes de protection
contre les attaques malveillantes qui
auront lieu de plus en plus soit encore
insuffisant l'ansi fait un travail
formidable
c'est encore insuffisant nous devons
sans cesse sensibiliser encore plus à la
fois les français à titre personnel le
niveau des attaques a augmenté
sensiblement pendant le confinement liée
aux niveaux d'utilisation mais également
les entreprises françaises des
institutions françaises et évidemment
les opérateurs de santé français merci
même prévu merci monsieur le ministre
mais quel que soit le soin que vous
aurez pris
les données des français pourront être
saisis par qui voudra s'en emparer et
c'est un problème et notamment pour ces
données là puisqu'elles sont
particulièrement intéressantes pour
diverses personnes et voir des états au
passage nous aurons aussi abandonner une
part de liberté or vous savez ce que
disait benjamin franklin à ce sujet un
peuple qui est prêt à sacrifier un peu
de liberté pour un peu de sécurité ne
mérite ni l'une ni l'autre et finit par
perdre les deux en prime nous aurons
aussi gagné une ambiance de défiance
généralisée ne faudrait-il pas plutôt
parié sur la confiance une confiance
réciproque qui s'est un peu perdu ces
derniers temps et à ce titre je voudrais
citer l'historien noir harry une
population informée et motivé est
beaucoup plus puissante et efficace
qu'une population ignorante et contrôlé
par la police
la citoyenneté est en effet un levier
puissant de réussite fédérateur par
essence c'est dommage d'oublier et de ne
pas actionner ce qui est constitutif de
notre république
je remercie merci donc la parole est
maintenant madame sophie primas dernière
intervenante
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat madame monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme bruno
retailleau l'a indiqué tout à l'heure je
serais plutôt satisfaites d'apporter mon
soutien à ce projet puisque celui ci
nous permet de revenir sur la notion de
souveraineté numérique senna mis en
exergue
l'année dernière lors de sa commission
denquête le gouvernement a donc décidé
de développer sa propre application en
vue d'accompagner le déconfinement je ne
souhaite pas revenir sur les nombreuses
à pori de ce projet qui ont été déjà
souligné je souhaite plutôt attirer
votre attention sur un point plus
discret du débat vous ne serez pas
étonnés monsieur le secrétaire d'état
mais un point non moins essentielle car
il souligne la potentielle impuissance
de l'état dans le monde numérique lors
de la genèse de l'application stop
qu'ovide le gouvernement s'est en effet
heurté à des refus de la part des deux
géants apple et google de lever
certaines barrières techniques sur leur
système d'exploitation
vous avez trouvé une astuce mais
admettez monsieur secrétaire d'état que
c'est inadmissible
la puissance publique s'est retrouvé en
réalité dans la position de n'importe
quel développeur d'application face au
duo paul apple google qui impose ses
conditions sans se justifier et dans des
conditions opaques
cette situation est d'autant moins
acceptable qu'elle aurait pu être
prévenue si un principe de neutralité
des smartphones avait été consacrée
comme le sénat l'a adopté dans une
proposition de loi de la commission des
affaires économiques
voté à l'unanimité de tous les groupes
politiques du sénat le 19 février
dernier
monsieur le ministre cette crise sans
précédent doit être l'occasion de tirer
les enseignements et les leçons pour
l'avenir de mettre fin aux errements du
passé et d'adopter un principe de
neutralité des terminaux le gouvernement
était le 19 février dernier sur ses
bancs favorable sur le fond à la
solution proposée par la commission mais
trouvait qu'il était sur la forme
prématuré d'adopter ce texte
au niveau national il y a là un peu
d'ironie s aujourd'hui est ce
qu'aujourd'hui expériences faites y
compris celle de l'échec du projet
européen
vous avez l'intention de porter de faire
inscrire ce texte à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur le ministre pour la
réponse monsieur le président madame la
présidente je l'aurais été déçu si
évidemment vous ne posez pas la question
qui est vital pour trouve là son cas
d'application le plus intéressant dans
le fond vous avez raison c'est ce qui
s'est passé est inadmissible aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas d'ailleurs les moyens
juridiques pour contraindre un peu les
google de modifier leur attitude dans ce
qui s'apparenterait si nous étions dans
le champ commercial à un abus de
position dominante
puis ce qui s'est passé c'est à peu près
ça vous avez une innovation vous me l'a
proposé je vais la faire moi même
et puis vous obliger à passer par mon
innovation bon ce sont des états qui
développe qui a pas d'intérêts
commerciaux ça ne rentre pas dans cette
classification
mais cela vient quelque part apporté de
l'eau au moulin de tous ceux et vous en
faites partie qui disent qu'il y à la
situation oligopolistique à un marché
fermé sur des infrastructures qui
pourrait s'apparenter à des
infrastructures essentielles
nous avions eu ce débat lorsque votre
proposition de loi était passé par le
sénat avait été présenté pour la
première fois et j'avais effectivement
dit que nous préférions pour des raisons
évidentes agir au niveau européen ce que
je sais c'est que le digital services
isaac pardon l'anglicisme devrait passer
d'ici la fin de l'année à la commission
avec des éléments importants et la
france y tiendra sur ces questions de
lutte de pratiques anti concurrentielles
mais allons-y un peu pour avoir un terme
un peu bateau la commission d'ailleurs a
eu des discussions continuent de la
crise du coït pour décaler ce texte en
2021 et la france a beaucoup posé pour
que nous ne détaillons pas ce texte
c'est quelque chose d'une annonce que
nous avons eu je crois ce matin oui hier
et nous étions très contents
le texte reste en 2020 et soit il assuré
que la france fera tout pour que ces
questions ces questions de régulation
des géants d'internet soit bien inclus
aux siens au sein du texte
s'il ne devait pas l'être je pense que
nous en reparlerions au niveau national
la madame la présidente
laissons l'année se termine et sa chance
à l'europe et envoyez-nous à ce moment
là merci monsieur le ministre à la
demande du gouvernement le sénat est
appelé à se prononcer pour un vote sur
cette déclaration conformément à
l'article 39 alinéa 6 de notre règlement
il va donc être procédé un scrutin
public ordinaire dans les conditions
prévues par l'article 56 du règlement
aucune explication de vote n'est admise
ce
voilà les sénateurs sont donc en train
de voter un par la bulle électronique
le scrutin est ouvert les sénateurs sont
donc en train de voter par voie
électronique
après un débat qui a donc débuté
maintenant il n'ya quasiment 2h30 un
débat assez serein d'abord consacrée à
la question de la protection collective
et de celle des libertés publiques alors
parmi les groupes on connaît déjà à peu
près les votes vont voter contre a
priori les communistes les socialistes
une partie du groupe uc le groupe union
centriste
avec aussi de l'abstention dans ce
groupe pour naturellement devraient
voter et bien le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle le groupe
lrm mais hosties et les indépendants et
surtout et bien le groupe
elle est majoritaire ici au sénat un oui
prudent ou du côté et bien des
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales alain milon du président de la
commission des lois
philippe bas un oui plus enthousiastes
du côté du président du groupe bruno
retailleau un peu vaut mieux que rien du
tout le président du groupe heller qui
s'est réjoui également qu'il s'agisse là
d'une application française et non issus
des gars femmes donc le scrutin est clos
on attend le résultat d'un instant à
l'autre
voici donc les résultats du scrutin
numéro 105 contenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 342 nombre de suffrages exprimés
313 pour l'adoption 186 contre 127 et
donc le sénat a approuvé la déclaration
du gouvernement
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance demain jeudi 28
mai à 9h pour l'examen de la proposition
de loi visant à porter un cadre stable
d'épanouissement et de développement aux
mineurs vulnérables sur le territoire
français très bien mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues que
bonne soirée
la séance est levée voilà vous l'avez vu
les sénateurs ont donc voté pour
l'application au stop qu'ovide résultat
à des votes 186 voix pour 127 voix
contre je le disais hé bien
effectivement le groupe ait l'air
notamment à voter pour l'application
stop qu'ovide c'est le principal
enseignement de ce vote finalement la
différence entre les élèves majoritaire
au sénat qui sont favorables à cette
application est au contraire à
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi et
bien les députés l air y étaient opposés
quelques points forts de ce débat il ya
eu un opposant passionnés notamment qui
s'est exprimé ce soir loïc hervé
sénateur uc membre de la cnil
farouchement opposée il a jugé que cette
application était inefficace et craint
également face au timing vous l'avez vu
en revanche est bien dans le groupe
heller un certain nombre de voir pour
des ouïes prudent du côté des présidents
des commissions que sont alain milon
philippe bas oui plus passionnés du côté
de bruno retailleau qui salue notamment
une application française à noter
également qu'il ya eu des questions
intéressantes des questions plus
spécialisés avec onze questions réponses
cédric au le secrétaire d'état
au numérique à la manoeuvre pour le
déploiement de cette application a tenté
de répondre aux très nombreuses
interrogations que l'on a pu entendre
malgré et bien son engagement gageons
qu'il n'a pas pu faire changer d'avis
les sénateurs qui étaient opposés ce
vote je le rappelle est un vote non
contraignant noter néanmoins que le
secrétaire d'état a annoncé de ce matin
qu'il n'y avait pas de déploiement sans
approbation du parlement donc après
l'approbation de l'assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure voilà qui l'a donc
l'approbation du sénat
il faut croire aussi et bien que
l'exécutif arabe et un certain nombre
d'assurances puisque cette application
doit être disponible d'ici quelques
jours dans un avenir très proche
notez enfin que et bien ce soir on a pu
voir et bien le président du sénat
gérard larcher sur les bancs du sénat
ils étaient présents ici sur les bancs
de l'hémicycle il a donc certainement pu
voter ce soir
voilà c'est la fin de cette soirée qui
était donc consacrée au débat sur
l'application stop qu'ovide au sénat je
vous souhaite une très bonne nuit sur
les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]